de star game
[Applaudissements]
winston churchill on va briefé notre
nouvel invité en paix que nous sommes en
direct sur internet que je suis avec
jérôme ceux-là clients bonjour jérôme
anger ont tué un joueur français donne
d'un bon niveau
crois-tu à 2300 points elo donc c'est un
excellent niveau puisque c'est pas loin
du niveau de maître international et tu
vas donc suivi ses premières parties de
ce match voit l'annoncé d'hier
directement lorsque tu avais
d'embellissement est ce que tu as vu le
coût de tourgéville 40 et chronique à la
fin c'est quand même si simplement
sébastien même pour l'ordinateur ça a
l'air d'être un gain connu en tout cas
puisque en interne et j'avais fatigué ce
qui était pas 4 c'est vrai donc la case
star vient d'arriver et à jouer ça y est
et bien dis là on peut dire que c'est
une victoire de kramnik puisque kasparov
si on peut montrer l'échiquier réel tout
de suite sur la position qui revient
c'est kasparov vient de jouer le coup
ces deux c4 et donc il admet sa défaite
il n'a pas trouvé de solution contre la
berlinoise de chroniques peut-être qu'il
attend simplement on avoir trouvé une
plus sûr mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
on peut bien penser qu'il a envie gagner
cette partie hier il a sauvé la partie
avec difficulté ont je pense qu'il veut
revenir dans le match tout de suite d'
attaques il a senti le problème relève
de chroniques
mais cros ne marche pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe voilà il me dit de vérifier mon
micro
voilà ce qu'on est ce qu on nous entend
ici est ce qu on nous entend or s'il
s'avère bon il faut que je rende parle
un peu plus près du micro voilà c'est
les problèmes techniques qui vont être
fusionnées début de partie alors peuvent
première surprise aujourd'hui c'est que
kramnik n'est pas encore là semble-t-il
il va avoir la surprise en arrivant à
peut-être s'était endormi parce que la
partie était très longue il hier on y
croit quand même pas voilà on a dû bien
travaillé ce matin chez krt à munich
l'un vérifier la berlinoise mais alors
qu rami on va passer à notre échiquier
de démonstration tout de suite
voilà très belle incrustation peut-être
essayer de réduire un petit peu l'image
en bas à droite ça doit être possible
et là on va voir que ici donc kasparov a
joué le coup c'est de ces quatre coups
un petit peu surprenant dans la mesure
où on s'attendait plutôt coup du pion du
roi de kasparov qui l'avait donc joué
dans les première et troisième partie
est semble-t-il comme il n'a pas réussi
à gagner
il change d'ouverture bon ceci dit ces
quatre c'est quand même pas de
nouveautés pour kasparov puisqu'il avait
déjà joué le sas et visions 87 contre
kharkov qui est pas non plus un client
facile donc évidemment kasparov peut
tout jouer au premier coup on sait pas
encore ce qu'il a choisi comme ça comme
ça et tout prix donc là
évidemment quand il n'est pas là donc ça
pose un petit problème notamment au
niveau du temps pour chronique puisque
ils perdent du temps actuellement à la
pendule
donc il faut espérer pour 8 qu' il va
arriver assez vite
la c4
dont kasparov donc là problèmes
chroniques quatre minutes de temps n'est
toujours pas arrivé alors il peut perdre
autant qu'on ne s'agira plus s'il n'y a
pas eu trop de problèmes de temps jusqu
ici quoique dans la partie d'hier on
peut se demander si avec un peu plus de
temps à la pendule il aurait pas trouvé
des gains par ils ont évident mais quand
même largement à sa portée
aussi qu'il est plus peut-être
simplement coincés dans les
embouteillages
s'il est peut-être concernera je pense
pas qu'il soit très loin d'ici je pense
que c'est peut-être voulu cette ce
retard ça arrive parfois dans les
matches comme ça ça met un peu de
pression qui corrige le voilà le voilà
il arrive maintenant peut-être un peu de
retard pour chroniques kasparov lui
serre la main et ils découvrent et là
ils découvrent que kasparov a joué le
coup ces deux c4 évidemment c'est une
petite victoire psychologique pour lui
mais un nouveau problème à résoudre
alors à noter que la grogne touche ces
pièces évident quand on touche une pièce
aux échecs on est obligé de la jouer
sauf quand on le dit auparavant
ja double il faut le dire d'ailleurs en
français je pense pas qu'il ait oublié
et voilà crâne il joue la défense
symétrique avec ses 7 c5 assez
rapidement d'ailleurs assez rapidement
mais on va tout à l'air impressionné en
or par ses cadres qu'à préparer kasparov
d'ailleurs il ya un crâne qui avait joué
assez vite également contre contre la le
gobie dame accepté de kasparov
alors que c'est il n'avait jamais joué
auparavant il se laisse pas tellement
impressionné en fait dans la préparation
kasparov apparemment oui kasparov la
même pas jouer avant mais on a eu avec
éloi et loi et ce avec une chronique
avait déjà gagné plein de victoires sur
cette ouverture voilà exactement
exactement même avec des français 5 qui
a l'air pourtant un peu un peu sec
on échange les dames ont des positions
techniques qui lui conviennent
parfaitement
on a réussi à bien manoeuvré ses
cavaliers
et à mettre la pression sur le quart
noir mais le coup j'ai 4 hier c'était
pour une partie fantastique de kramnik
vous aurez mérité la victoire
un début de partie dans la première
moitié de la partie
j'avais assez impressionnant kramnik
répondent toujours par la symétrie pour
l'instant donc tout va jouer kasparov
est ce qu'une quatre formations
maintenant g2 g3 probablement s'est joué
cavalier c3 également cavale et ses
trois des quatre aussi beaucoup de coups
possible de choisir son seul son schéma
vasco et là on dirait que
1 on irait que kasparov n'est
malheureusement pas capable de sortir
des nouveautés théorie contre kramnik
qui décidément arrive à lui poser des
problèmes dès les premiers coups de
l'ouverture où les nouveautés théorique
vont venir
un peu plus tard faut toujours se méfier
de caspar en fait de sa préparation
je pense qu'il devrait bien l'anglais
c'est vraiment pas gratuit et qui doit
avoir quelques réserves en stop donc on
va voir pendant kasparov réfléchi la
position effectivement donc là je rentre
tout nous dit que c'est une ouverture
qui s'appelle l'ouverture anglaise voilà
l'ongle asymétrique avec ses 5
je pense que c'est ce que jean cras on y
vient pour un match à l'ombre voilà je
fais comment est-ce que c'est une
dédicace s'est pas trop bon mais c'est 5
c'est ce que je chronique assez
régulièrement je crois donc la
possibilité pour castres kasparov jouer
j'ai trois pour mettre le fou f1 ici sur
la case g2 et puis une possibilité
bouger le cavalier ici bien
éventuellement sur la case d3 ou encore
de jouer des cadres des deux des quatre
trois possibilités ici qui sont marqués
en verre pour kasparov et qui sont
toutes équivalent jouer à haut niveau et
d'ailleurs il me semble bien qu'ils ont
eu ce genre de position avec couleurs
inversées et a pas si longtemps on crame
mika joue une variante avec g3 celui
qu'avait laissé 3 et des quatre systèmes
qui qu'il est seul à jouer peut-être que
ses parents fallait
et encore toujours pas pourquoi c'est
incroyable la facilité avec laquelle
cramique pose des problèmes
psychologiques à kasparov dès les
premiers coups c'est vrai que contre à
chaque fois on s'ancre à munich très
serein vraiment ils arrivent à ses 4 ou
qu'elles ne devaient pas s'attendre et
joue tout tu te ses coûts et sa
préparation n'est pas impressionné se
pose pas de l'instrument fors2 kasparov
qui résidait dans la hotte d'un
l'ouverture mais capable de surprendre
et de gagner des parties rien qu'en
connaissant déjà la préparation maison
et la micra munich
mais pour le moment c'est vrai que dans
l'ouverture kasparov a pas pas montré
grand chose pour le moment dans le match
il a finalement pas réussi à passer les
berlinoise et il a été deux fois
vraiment orangé avec les noirs à la g3
kasparov a choisi la première option g3
l'idée est simple c'est que les blancs
veut placer le mot fin sur la 4g 2 et
contrôler ainsi la grande diagonale
blanche et notamment la casse des 5
c'est notamment la dgrad typique de
l'anglais sont des 5 et probablement
cramique peut répliquer par le coup
symétrique
encore une fois j'ai six cavaliers c6 ou
blessées si ce geste si ce qui est
possible et mettre lui-même son pouce la
casse g7
travnik que en fait ne risque pas de
grosses nouveautés théorie dans cette
variante parce que c'est une ouverture
rampante un peu comme ça ça dépend enfin
ça dépend vraiment du schéma qui
choisissent souvent c'est vrai que ça
donne lieu à des parties assez
positionnelle mais quelques quelques
variantes ou les noirs jouent voilà ce
notamment des variantes avec 5
wouah où c'est chaud la chronique joue
le 17 des 5 voilà il se bat tout de
suite pour le centre et c'est vrai
qu'ils sont des variantes heures alors
là c'est un chaussage étendue et ça a
l'air
kasparov encore toujours très expressif
y allèrent en difficulté il se dit mais
je m'attendais pas encore à ça la la la
la la
ce qui nous fait pas la ola je ne vous
fait pas un peu de cinéma aussi
non mais j'ai moins simple à chaque fois
de toute façon il festo tête et à chaque
fois il en prend pour son matricule le
port kramnik engage les courbes à dès
les premiers coups il n'a pas peur une
seconde une seconde de kasparov
il n'a pas peur du tout du tout du tout
d'une quelconque préparation c'est la
moutte kasparov kasparov
il n'y a pas de bluff dans ce match y'a
pas de bluff dans ce match du tout parce
que ici oh lalala lalala cramique est en
train de contre-attaquer kasparov avec
probablement larmes la plus tranchante
dans cette interview il se veut tout de
suite pour le centre c'est une réaction
à ces scènes donc la lignée de kramnik
évidemment ces deux contre-attaqués au
centre et de poser un problème au plomb
c4 et puis tout de suite les noirs
occupe le centre contrôle tellement la
classe de 4 avec le pion et puis
donc ça pose un problème en noir ou
blanc s comprend des cinq faut réagir au
centre tout de suite et dès que
l'opération est central sa peau tout ça
propose des complications tactique alors
il ya d'autres options pour les blancs
qui consiste aussi à laisser le centre
des variantes où ils vont jouer ou g2
cavalli c3 laisser les noirs jo cavalli
c6 et e5 essayer de contrôler centre à
distance une approche un peu moderne
d'intéressantes sont toujours des
variantes aiguë je crois que l'écho je
me sens assez souvent avec les noix
peter les cours frappe les gérants de
peter les océanes des meilleurs joueurs
du monde puisqu'il est classé numéro 5
ou 6 mondial actuellement sinon s'ils se
croient très fort je voudrais aussi un
des joueurs qui apparemment pas trop
impressionné par kasparov ses mimiques
et d'actes manqués le personnage
exactement de pita l'icône n'a pas peur
de kasparov
ça fait partie de la génération montante
voilà les jeunes - impressionnable que
peut-être les anciens adversaires de
kasparov
il pose là monde ça y est comme
d'habitude ça y est kasparov
ça met en position de de jeu on l'a on
l'a souligné à chaque fois il des faits
ça montre c'est son rituel est là qui
rentre vraiment dans la partie
aïe aïe aïe aïe kasparov déjà surpris
par le coup de g nick alors probablement
il peut prendre alors quelles sont les
possibilités pour les pour les blancs on
va voir sur notre échiquier de
démonstration tout de suite alors
ailleurs alors là évidemment je nous
revois
voilà les blancs peuvent ici prendre le
dessert c'est le coup classique et
lennon pascal à reprendre et du cavalier
pour ne pas exposer la dame puisque si
la dame reprenait un des cinq clés blanc
pourrait gagner en temps en sortant
leurs cavaliers j'aurais simplement
cavaliers ces trois organes des étangs
pour développement ici les blancs menace
ricard et ses trois gagnants le temps
sur la dame donc il faut prendre du
cavalier donc c'est une possibilité pour
kasparov
autre possibilité que nous site du rhum
je vous fous gedo tranquillement on n'a
pas peur de la prison c4 parce que c'est
pas vraiment au pire en pire les blancs
peuvent toujours faire damas quatre
échecs et reprendre le pion récupérer le
pion ceci je crois que c'est prendre le
sens et 400 dessins qui a un truc là si
elle est là kasparov et déjà out of
préparer chez nous alors c'est peut-être
une possibilité aussi de kasparov de il
sait gérer les matches passent pas en
face il faut faire attention on peut
être aujourd'hui il veut jouer une
variante vous ne risque pas de perdre et
il prépare toujours des solutions contre
la berlinoise en backstage comme voilà
c'est possible bon ceci dit je pense
quand même qu'il va jouer vraiment pour
le gars aujourd'hui parce qu'il y ait en
fait c'est son premier résultat vraiment
positif du match jusqu'ici il avait
perdu les noirs annulé avec les blancs 1
milliard pour la première fois ils
annulent bon c'est vrai avec de la
chance avec les noirs donc qu'est-ce
qu'un effet qui sent pas que c'est le
moment de deux essayer de gagner
il émerge jeu il sort un peu de l'eau
kasparov depuis hier un email
justin il a juste un peu là le nez au
dessus de l'eau il peut respirer un coup
sarek rami qui a joué et gagné vu de
façon très de façon très impressionnante
mais ensuite il ya il a un peu faibli et
on sait que donc elle soit faut trouver
quand même d'excellentes ressources
défensive pour poser un maximum de
problèmes chroniques s'y méprendre voilà
c'est unique passe et pas que de la
chance évidemment c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui c'est probable qu'ils
tentent tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
aller chercher cramique sur un nouveau
schéma a donc rappelé que le match est
relativement court 16 parties et que
donc les occasions malgache et ses
occasions j'ai bien sûr tout qu'on s'est
cramé perrin vers vraiment quasiment
jamais avec way ont rappelé avec la loi
qu'il avait perdu contre adams en
juillet ça faisait presque 80 81 parties
je crois qu'il a perdu avec les deux
couleurs il me semble qu'avec les avec
les blancs il et il n'a jamais perdu
contre kasparov en partie exact m héry
fier mais était jusque là on n'a jamais
réussi à battre chronique avec les
pièces noirmont évidemment il a battu
deux fois trois fois avec les pièces
blanches
donc il sait le battra les pistes
blanches c'est déjà arrivé mais kramnik
était un peu plus jeunes et à mika
maintenant 25 ans non partie long qui
vous en main kasparov a pas battus
cramique depuis 97 nous l'a vérifié mais
ouais c'est probable c'est probable bon
joueur très solide
je pense pas qu'ils gâchent la couleur
kasparov il a vraiment aller le chercher
enfin rappelé que les joueurs ces
joueurs là se rencontrent dans les
tournois du grand chelem entre
guillemets des échecs on va vous
expliquer ça à vous qui suivez et
découvrez les échecs
grâce à ce programme sur canal web
et bien que ces tournois se font partie
du grand chelem il ya le tournoi devait
casey qui à côté d' amsterdam en
hollande très grands tournois ou
kasparov participent quasiment à chaque
fois il ya aussi le tour nable de
linares qui est probablement le plus
prestigieux qui est surnommé le
wimbledon des échecs ou l'aller cette
année par exemple citer les six
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui était là
meilleur joueur du monde se rend compte
régulièrement dans ces tournois et
plusieurs fois par an est d'ailleurs
kasparov a eu des résultats quand même
assez impressionnant cette année tout à
fait il a presque tout gagné dans cette
ombre il a gagné les camps dit elvia
linares ensuite il a gagné sarajevo sur
le fil shirov aurait pu gagner ce
tournoi mais il a faibli sur la fin a
perdu une partie et finalement il
termine second et un demi point et
kasparov gagne quand même ces trois
dernières rondes
on voulait vraiment aller chercher le
tronc du combattant tout à fait donc ça
s'était cassé de sarajevo est en fait le
quatrième tournoi du grand chelem c'est
probablement le tournoi de dortmund
melaka sport ne participe à ce tournoi
qui est un tournoi qui réussit bien
cramique d'habitude pourrait tout à fait
de la gagne et multiples reprises il
semble bien que c'est la première année
où quelques trames n'y gagne pas s'il a
gagné cette année encore en ex-aequo
ex-aequo avec un angle l'année dernière
c'est l'écho qu'il avait gagné et avant
kramnik avait gagné trois fois de suite
voilà en tout cas qu'à sports
visiblement surpris par des 5 on peut
pas dire qu'il soit hors de préparation
ce qui évidemment des connaissances
complètement encyclopédique mais
visiblement surpris il est surpris
encore une fois c'est bon évidemment il
connaît cette position le premier palace
et le problème est dans leurs choix
psychologique des variantes kasparov a
essayé encore une fois aujourd'hui
probablement de poser des problèmes à
kramnik différents de ceux de
du gouverneur e 4 malheureusement mais
ils se rendent compte que kramnik n'a
peur de rien pourquoi parce que d'abord
cramique a joué très vite et ensuite
parce que cramique il choisit
probablement la variante la plus aiguë
et décontracté a vraiment les deux bouts
granic est pas ici à se demander quel
schéma il va employer une impression qu
racing n'a pas du tout peur d'eux des
complications ne sera pas du tout peur
de calculer et de rentrer alors que
karpov et kasparov vous pouvez jouer
psychologiquement car peu après que la
preuve ne vient pas trop peut-être les
grandes complications et il est prêté un
joueur que c'est un joueur car pour
qu'ils servent plutôt enfin évidemment
il est fabuleux calculateur aussi mais
qui préférait un petit peu attendant son
adversaire c'est de l'étouffer
effectivement et kasparov s'est
peut-être pas comment prendre à munich
en fait pour le moment
enfin il a tellement d'idées dans ses
positions sans dame qui l'a obtenu à
répétition dans le train dans le match
par dont il ya vraiment eu des problèmes
je crois que pour la première fois
qu'est ce qu'on joue contre un joueur
qui a probablement un style qui est
proche du sien mais qu'ils le jouent
normalement en plus c'est qu'ils le
jouent ensemble c'est ça qui fait la
différence
exactement elle qui n'a pas peur il n'a
pas bougé 4 par exemple ça prouve
vraiment peut-être contraindre un autre
grand maître aurait proposé nul dans la
partie d'hier dans cette position qui
avait l'air assez plate crown et joue
oui il joue il vérifié et la raison une
a raison parce que le match est court
c'est lui qui depuis l'a 25 ans et créer
quatre points à 37
mais peut-être intérêt à jouer à fond de
toutes les parties pour voir lequel la
meilleure résistance faut se méfier de
l'âge comme kasparov vraiment un homme
qui est habitué à jouer des matches
longs
et on se souvient par exemple du match
marathon contre karpov où il était mené
5 0 où il tenait à la fin il a regagné 3
parties c'est vraiment un joueur qui
tient la distance mais bon pour le
moment on a l'impression qu'il a surtout
du mal à rentrer dans le match en fait
puisqu'il n'a pas fait preuve d'un jeu
très impressionnant a raté des points de
tactique on a l'impression qu'ils ratent
jamais exactement
hier par exemple cavaliers f4 c'était un
peu surprenant il a joué alors qu'il lui
restait un quart d'heure il avait deux
options il joue un coup il ya un bar am
en perdant très rapidement ouais ouais
ouais alors qu'un coup ils jouent pas
tellement compliqué le laisser dans la
partie il vous permet d'acheter un
chrono de jouer cavalier 4 alors qu'ils
assuraient probablement assez facilement
la nulle c'est vraiment des fautes qu'on
a pas l'habitude de le voir là les
embêter encore il suffit d'un regard des
casseroles pour deviner comment comment
il est dans la partie que moi ils se
sont hélas il est embêté bon il fait un
peu de cinéma aussi parfois quand il
voit quand il considère que le coût de
l'adversaire est pas bon c'est vrai il
fait bien sentir bon là ça apparemment
ce n'est pas le cas mais tout cas
visiblement ses dessins que c'est un
schéma auquel il s'attendait et non dans
cet ordre de coup on était sûr il
n'attend pas il s'attendait pas à cette
chronique vous fait il mieux jouer quand
on est joueur
kasparov qui ont un peu peur et qui
laisse venir un peu les blancs c'est la
meilleure des familles il est tellement
fort dans ses positions ou l'initiative
quand c'est un bon choix de krainik dois
vraiment me cramique veut le combat tout
de suite tout de suite le combat est
donc ça veut dire que kramnik lutte
aussi pour l'initiative et que donc la
kasparov et face à un style qui est prof
probablement semblable au sien et aussi
quand même qu rami qui a montré une
grande force pour tenir les positions ou
un oui on a l'impression qu'ils
souffrent un petit peu c'est berlinoise
qu'il a réussi à simplifier la somme
qu'il a un grand jugement objectif des
positions et qui il n'a pas peur
chronique est là kasparov est en train
déjà de prendre du temps pour choisir
ses coûts allez c'est peut-être du temps
qui va encore lui manquer aujourd'hui
une bonne douzaine de minutes pour son
quatrième coup des gens alors que c'est
lui qui était censé avoir surpris crâne
normes alors la claise qu'une petite
jouer encore une fois il peut jouer
options prendre des cinq éventuellement
il peut jouer aussi fou j'ai deux bien
sûr l'on se demande pas ça sur
l'échiquier de démonstration tu demandes
passage à jouer maintenant il en fait en
train de choisir sur le son schéma un
peu plus long terme
donc là il faut que kasparov choisisse
une de ses coûts on voit pas trop quel
autre coup il pourrait jouer de toute
façon dans cette ouverture faut soit je
vous fous j'ai de soi qu a blessé trois
noms soient qui comprend des 5es pas
trop le choix
effectivement qu'est-ce-qui pourquoi il
réfléchit il a 80 ans et ça va quand
même pas deux heures pour choisir un
coup alors effectivement je pense qu'il
choisit surtout les variantes qui va
jouer après il connaît très bien les
possibilités des noirs et a décidé la
fnaim a décidé images ou est ce qui fait
je vous dis un coup il choisit comprend
des sacs
voilà il a choisi d'être né cinq voix la
chronique va répondre tout de suite
cavaliers prend pions des 5
c'est le coût obligatoires pas de
problème cramé qui tient sa cravate
tranquille il ya vu le coup dans sa loge
hinault tranquillement nous coûte
l'espoir vous allez voir que l'ukraine
me vois pas mettre deux heures à
répondre
le coup est quasiment forcé voilà
cavaliers prend pionne des cinq
maintenant question que ce sport peut
encore se poser laquelle il a joué tout
de suite fou j'ai 2 dont il a pris un
peu de temps et que je vais probablement
un peu plus vite mais non il a choisi
dans la rue si la ligne
exactement il a choisi maintenant son
ouverture kasparov donc les couvents
aller plus vite et la pluie chronique
tranquille développe ses pièces
cavaliers c6 kasparov répond par
cavaillé c3 ça y est c'est enclenché
l'ouverture est en train de se jouer
voilà lancés dans cette position qu'on
peut jouer des schémas couleurs un peu
curieux avec cavaliers c7
alors on peut en
visage et le cou de cramique cavaliers
pardon ici sur la case
c'est cette voie là c'est un peu de
prophylaxie on retient le cavalier de la
case des cinq parce qu'on dessin qui
pourrait arriver quelques bricoles au
noir en d5 qui avant ce quart est
attaqué par le cas les c3 et par le fou
j'ai deux en transparence et par le faut
je donne effectivement en transparence
par rayons x comme un billet loi par
exemple quand les noirs jouent des coups
comme eux 7 5 il est blanc peuvent jouer
cavalier f3 prend le 5
voilà il faut vérifier bien sûr mais ces
attaques deux fois le cavalier imaginons
tout de suite d'ailleurs par exemple que
si les noirs jouent une scène qui s'y
voit là il faut vérifier la vendre
cavaliers prendre 5 à 20 qui peut être
possible ces cavaliers prendre sur une
scène et après 15 années prendre cavani
par exemple récupérer la pièce on
descend récupère la pièce en d5 avec le
fou voilà bon évidemment il ya d'autres
possibilités parce que les blancs et les
noirs pourraient prendre en c3 mais ce à
quoi les blancs jour répondre à quatre
ans et six cd vraiment à calculer il des
variantes calculer mais c'est des
possibilités
kasparov et aller aux toilettes
semble-t-il on dit point important du
match là alors ça y est la cramique
choisi le coup g7 g6 voilà il rentre
dans une possibilité simple de symétrie
il veut mettre son fou sur laquelle g7
et contrôler lui aussi la grande
diagonale noir il trouve une bonne place
pour le fou noir parce que le fou noir
est un peu obstrué par le pion c5
voilà si on peut voir l'échiquier de
démonstration pendant que les blancs
contrôler la grande diagonale blanche
les noirs vont mettre un flou sur la
case g7 pour contrôler eux-mêmes la
grande diagonale noir donc grande
symétrie est par contre il ya une petite
dissymétrie évidemment dans la position
c'est les structures de pions les blancs
est un pion central de plus ils ont
gardé le pion des besoins les pions des
contrats pions le pion cd noir mais le
pion ces contrôles bien de son antre il
est la casse des cadres
voilà c'est une position où le centre va
jouer un grand rôle
lequel des joueurs va réussir à
s'imposer au centre le problème pour les
noirs probablement ça va être de savoir
où mettre ce fou ces huit ici et pour
les blancs le problème va se poser la
même façon pour le fou en c1 voilà
beaucoup de flèches donc la salle
kasparov de jouer les cramique jeu quand
même des schémas à ses cendres parce
qu'ici c'est un joueur qui a évolué en
fait quand il était plus jeune et je
fais des choses assez tendu par exemple
sur quatre y jouer la sicilienne je fais
schennikov effectivement et il est passé
à des schémas vraiment solide qui fait
qui perd très peu de parties d'ailleurs
là on peut se poser la question c'est de
la position actuelle des deux joueurs
c'est à kasparov de jouer est-ce que
kasparov pas envisager le coût des deux
des quatre alors tendu des données car à
pattes ça va être un peu prématuré d2 d4
donc on peut jouer peut-être d2 d3 dans
cette position dit je vais parler
simplement petit rock peut probablement
petit rock dans le roi à l'abri il joue
un coup inutile on attend les décisions
mettant la tour en jeu
là on est toujours dans l'ouverture pour
l'instant pas de surprise dans cette
ouverture c'est une ouverture connu les
joueurs réfléchissent non pas parce
qu'ils connaissent pas les couilles mais
parce qu'il sait de choisir la variante
qui va convenir le plus à leur style
je corrige kasparov réfléchi parce que
pour le moment g knicks et impôts ouais
quatre ans vous aussi un peu parce qu'il
est rami qui n'est pas impressionné ce
mot de passe question où il a sa
préparation y croire il joue ses schémas
usuelles c'est vrai
chronique ne se pose pas de question
dans ce match et c'est le problème de
kasparov
il n'y a plutôt l'habitude de rencontrer
des joueurs qui ont un peu peur de lui
et là il tombe contre le joueur
impassible
on va avoir droit à une partie ce
probablement très tendu à moins que
kasparov propose une nulle rapide ce qui
est quand même pas le style de la maison
ce qui est pas le style de la maison et
qui serait encore une fois un aveu de
faiblesse
kasparov en difficulté
en tête a encore sa tête des mauvais
jours ci et alors là évidemment la
question qui va se poser si au bout de
trois ou quatre heures de jeu c'est la
forme des joueurs après la partie d'hier
une partie très difficile avec des
rebondissements et joueurs avaient l'air
un peu ko à la conférence de presse oui
qui a pas trop duré oui tout à fait
granic visiblement déçu gspr offre
vivait un peu cette partie était bien
content d'avoir tiré son nid points oui
c'est vrai que ça a un petit rôle de
team est récurrente
normal on arrive à prévoir les coûts à
peu près des joueurs tranquilles
kasparov la chronique doit jouer le coup
g7 c'est sûr c'est quasiment sûr il va
jouer tout de suite
chronique alors l affaire et la caisse
quand bof bof pas l'air super satisfait
et oui il n'arrive pas à placer ses
préparations de théorique kasparov
bouscule pas krainik dans des buts et
non il bouscule pas du tout crédit dans
le début quand ils jouent faux g7 et là
hop un petit coup de cassayet provoquant
damas quatre ans à ses petits coups
provoquant parce que sa menace des
choses par exemple on peut il envisager
je sais pas peut-être leur dame à 4 par
un ca en clouant qui avait lié ces six
ça va permettre de limiter contrôle des
noirs sur la case des quatre donc juste
la 10e cavaliers c6 est cloué puisque la
dame 1 4i s'y attaquent directement le
roi mais évidemment il suffit que les il
suffit que les noirs rock et ça enlève
toute velléité à ce coup là on voit pas
trop il peut toujours jouer des plans
comme ça fait partie d'une ouverture
dans un kart comme une possibilité c'est
vrai il peut jouer des coups comme
damage quatre ans suite des choses un
peu bizarre on échange en camion des 5
il peut envisager m ici le la dame sur
la case h4 tu as des plans qu'on
retrouve parfois dans l'essentiel et
ensuite le cavaliere 3 qui viennent
assure la case g5 pour attaquer le point
faible h7
ou alors plus positionnement parfois les
blancs peuvent jouer ça pour échanger
les fous noir en jouant des deux des
trois îles en échangeant probablement le
cavalier d'abord en d5
puis fou c'est 1 h 6 pour tg par l'adam
h4 qui essayent de supprimer ce beauf ou
de faire enquête et aux noix bon ça
c'est un peu ce fou noir ici sur la case
g7 qu'il faut peut-être arrivé à
échanger contre le fou sur la casse et
un ici et comme ça on aurait peut-être
fait un troc intéressant alors damas
quatre on peut se dire les noirs peuvent
repousser la dame en fait avec cavaliers
b6 mais on le cavaly serait pas bien
placé sur sa case donc c'est pas une
possibilité vraiment à craindre pour les
blancs qui jouerait vous êtes damage
théâtre peut-être dame ces deux ans et
bien rien de nouveau sous le soleil
cette position est connue cramique la
connaît il va simplement choisir son
coup de [ __ ]
on n'a pas de on n'a pas de date à base
suffisamment forte actuellement pour
voir mais c'est pas grave on va on se
concentre
ar mais voilà donc et loire où l'enjeu
qui nous rejoint un petit peu ça suffit
même pas bonjour et loire bonjour jérôme
bienvenue sur diagonale merci on est
bien reçu
tout à fait bien reçu temps d'installer
le micro c'est pas facile non c'est même
très compliqué en fait une installation
de micro puisque celui ci m'a l'air un
peu explosé joueur d'échecs sont pas
toujours très habiles de leurs mains
voilà les grands maîtres oui c'est pas
bon là c'est complexe
c'est hyper complexe ces mêmes
c'est même très très difficile il ya
donc un énorme problème
voilà la première victime chez diagonale
alors un micro je vais donc appelé notre
ingé son pour qu'ils viendraient parler
de micro puisque là le micro est cassée
alors bon ce n'est pas grave donc ici
chronique joue cavalier en b 6 voilà
elle repousse la dame
voilà ça y est la cavalerie est arrivé
pour une raison droillard de garry
kasparov qui a l'air bien surpris par un
cavalli b6 ah oui alors que cellou
principal tout simplement dans cette
position kébé 6 c'est le coup qu'on joue
habituellement je crois quand j'ai aussi
petit rock mais damas quatre népalais à
vanessa la réputée principal au
effectivement ok merci des clés noires
chasse immédiatement la dame lorsque le
cavalier bien placés en b 6
eh bien c'est possible petites secondes
qui avait b6 vient d'être jouée si on
peut passer sur cet échiquier de
démonstration voilà c'est fait qu'un v6
attaque la dame la dame on doit bouger
ou va-t-elle année jérôme probablement
très long de l'autre côté et non 20 h 4
ou et c'est un plan qui te parlais tout
à l'heure
sinon est-ce qu'on peut essayer
d'envisager datta khel tuant ses cinq ça
paraît un peu ridicule avec des messages
avec l'âme des 5
la dame dans la fosse aux lions voilà
surprenant mais néanmoins possible temps
et ça a l'air un peu savoureux exotique
mais bon est-ce que kraft pourrait
sacrifier un pion on en sait il pourra
le faire mais je sais pas ce qu'il a
envie de le faire même mais ça sans
visage quand même jérôme briot et c'est
vrai que c'est pas si simple de protéger
ce pion on pourrait placer le qui avait
six sur la case 17
on peut même jouer des coups étranges
comme ces quatre peut-être alors
attention
oui c'est tout à fait bon il faut le
considérer
ça va être mieux les dames les cinq un
coup un peu bizarre damages qui à
travers un poil plus naturel quand même
en tout cas kasparov répond pas
immédiatement alors que c'est quand même
apparemment des deux courts principaux
cavalli bessif alors est ce qu'il a
l'air vraiment à l'aise dans ce début
est ce qu'il a réussi son effet de
surprise
on dirait que non puisque effectivement
après ces quatre ya pas de candidat il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont évités en
tournée conséquemment normes et peu
intéressant mais il faut quand même
retravaillé les barrages en qui lèverait
anglaise voilà avec c4 c5 et c4 5
voilà donc avant de les ramener avec les
blancs à envisager tous les ses quatre
premiers coups à bien analyser ce genre
de position est donc là il est très
tranquille puisqu'il déroule sa
préparation il a eu peur de ça ils
avaient peur de ça tout simplement et
donc ils le jouent avec les noirs en
cinq minutes on toujours pas
impressionné alors quelque chose qu'il
faudrait voir je crois si je ne me suis
pas trompé c'est dans cette position là
le coût principal
voilà en fait ce qui je voudrais juste
revenir puisqu'on n'a pas mentionné mais
je crois que dans cette position là
après qui sait si ce qu'ils essaient 3g
voilà on joue des données qui est
dessiné il me semble que c'est ça le
coup ou réfuter réputé bon pour les
blancs enfin les angles aigus mais ça
serait le dernier cri des langues telles
que je les connaissais et pas si
longtemps que ça des deux des cats a
priori est elle beaucoup ici en tout cas
le coût qui assure et oblongs un léger
avantage sans âme sans aucun risque
alors que en continuant tel qu'il l'a
fait garry kasparov prend effectivement
quelques risques dans cette position
d'un dessin tu n'es pas jouer c'est la
pression des joueurs que l'on soit
l'échiquier kasparov doit bouger saddam
mais pour l'instant il perd du temps et
sortir la dame comme 124 comme on dit
aux débutants ça a l'air complètement
idiot jérôme voilà il faut bien la
mettre quelque part quand même et
peut-être que kasparov et quand même
bien content d'avoir gardé les dames
ayant il les a pas vus longtemps dans ce
match c'est une pièce qui l'apprécient
et menacé peut-être l'idée de l'
anglaise en fait 4 il avait compris
qu'il ne pouvait pas garder les dames
voilà que ça disparaît assez vite mais
peut-être qu'il ya un peu frustré dans
ce match oui ça va être la première
partie où les dames vous restez en jeu
mais normal avantage d'avoir les dames
encore sur l'échiquier sait qu'on peut
faire des attaques violentes mais enfin
ici ça l'a un peu compromis côté
attaques violentes
voilà pour les anglaises pas exactement
ça
donc là donc je suppose que tu as suivi
toutes les parties de ce match et
heureusement tu as tout malheureusement
pas tous pu enfin c'est vers la
troisième affaire la troisième et donc
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire quelles sont
les remarques qu'on peut dire sur l'état
de forme de ses deux joueurs garry
kasparov contre krainik d'alors kasparov
a quand même pas l'air très très en
forme c'est une telle clé au niveau de
jeu assez élevé de cramique mais je fais
des fautes tactiques qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de le voir faire et puis
surtout dans le début il est moins
percutant
voilà ce retour normalement contre la
plupart des joueurs il sort avec des
positions assez forts du début des
positions qui lui conviennent très bien
compliqué où il peut vraiment battre et
là il ya toujours eu des positions assez
sèche techniques qui ont l'air de moins
lui convient donc oui alors ça c'est pas
forcément désinforme c'est peut-être
krainik en fait qu'ils arrivent à lui a
imposé son style son style technique
laborieux
limite un petit peu ennuyeux mais enfin
c'est un style quand même voilà quoi que
hier la partie c'est bien animé quand
même et c'est vrai que cette partie par
toujours par toujours passer de la
troisième était c'était bien animé aussi
à partir du moment où ça avait l'air
tout à fait égal garric et avoir un coût
un peu tendu il aurait peut-être mais
simplifié avec 30 points f2 cavalli des
cas et je joue un peu tendu et là ça
s'est enflammé on may cry michela aussi
quand il s'agit de calculer tokyo etc et
des 4 1 peut-être de mémoire de mémoire
d'accord moi donc je ne sais plus très
bien dans tout cas il ya des parties
très chaude dans ce match ici garry
kasparov champion du monde champion du
monde depuis 15 ans quand même il faut
bien le rappeler est en pleine réflexion
et il fait la mine habituel c'est-à-dire
un peu ce qu'il veut
qu'est ce qu'elle est ce que je fais
dans cette position il ya un travers
très content un peu surpris c'est
étonnant donc on a du mal à croire que
trois des cinq fasse pas partie de sa
préparation quand même et que cavalli b6
donc lui d'ailleurs ça a l'air d'être
une vrai surprise salaire de député
garry kasparov qui nous fait maintenant
ça devient tout les jour quotidiennement
un cinéma dans l'ouverture cinéma pas
possible alors qu'il connaît évidemment
bien cette position à la gaude et tout
ça par coeur en effet la foire aux
grimaces et c'est totalement la foire
aux grimaces non mais ici y'a judy ya
pas de damas trois ans qu'on joue aussi
dans cette position jeu
je ne suis pas sûr tout à fait mais d'un
mètre en somme qu'on peut mettre la dame
dont 23 sont peu voire l'échiquier de
démonstration voilà damas 3 je crois que
c'est possible et où va garry kasparov
en bessin qu allah il est très chaud
gary neal est très très chaud il joue
dame b 5 qui a pas fait le voyage pour
rien il va vérifier s'il peut prendre
ces options il va le faire
oui mais comme venus de moscou pour
jouer sauvage effectivement donc
d'amener 5 et bats toi de jouer crown
est normalement cram devrait jouer qui
avait 17 pour un match à londres ça fait
plaisir
damman b5 au bout de vingt neuf coups
des échecs l'exotique des échecs et oui
alors effectivement on y mange
régulièrement aux débutants ne sortez
pas votre dame trop tôt pour quoi et
bien simplement parce que votre
adversaire va l'attaquer et vous allez
perdre du temps donc ici il ya un
kasparov complètement ailleurs
il est complet il retomber en enfance
garry kasparov puisqu'il a sorti ça
donne très vite en se disant peut-être
c'est ma pièce la plus forte je vais
aller lui piquer toutes ces pièces à
chaque malade je pense que tu devrais
lui en parler il serait ravi
probablement on lui posera la question à
voir la conférence de presse je serai
bien accueilli ouais tout à fait comme
le
saab aux journalistes hier il y avait vu
une fourchette
évidemment qu'ils n'existaient pas et
guérir c'est par un reflux est
judicieusement consiste à acheter un
ordinateur
voilà tout à fait d'ailleurs un
ordinateur kasparov peut être propre
peuple donc ici alors on va jeter un
oeil à l'échiquier démonstration puisque
c'est intéressant
c'est très intéressant la dame est venue
en b 5 voilà garry kasparov sur sa dame
très vite attaque l'option c5 et on se
demande ce qu'il se passe g jona et 17
l'idée bien sûr une des idées peut être
de jouer à cette assise peut être de
jouer qu'avec ses six en d4
bref il ya de nombreuses possibilités
pour attaquer cette dame alors ça me
fait penser un peu la partie d'hier on
crame nickel jouer cavalier quatre baies
3 5 ou on recule une pièce mécanique
attaqué un pion qui est pas si simple à
défendre il faut mettre ces pièces sur
des mauvaises case peut-être celle on a
des petits coups ennuyeux crâne et qu'il
y en avait fait un dalit cavaliers assez
impressionnant puisque il avait voulu
bouger ses cavaliers toujours sur des
positions inattendue ça commençait par
cahiers des deux au début ensuite ils
n'étaient pas les bons cavaliers
apparemment mais c'était tout à fait sa
force et travailler pièce noire sur une
case toujours un peu moins bonne
concessif bizarre fous ces huit là à mon
avis comme à une kasparov a vu plus loin
il faut bien faut bien le dire un gary
kasparov c'est quand même pas le premier
venu
c'est pas parce qu'il est mené dans ce
match qu'il n'est pas favori il est
quand même favori ici hilali saddam en
v5
on ne sait pas pourquoi vous le voyez à
droite sur votre applique à la voilà
vous voyez aussi ici en direct sur la
vidéo est donc que peu joué kasparov ici
et bien envisageons des coûts par
exemple le coût kamali aux 4 qui une
fois de plus tu ressembles à une faute
de débutant
puisque ça joue encore avec la même
pièce c'est l'exotisme le plus total
mais là ça a l'air très bizarre ce coup
je ne comprends pas l'idée a priori bon
c'est dasa camion c'est simple mais si
on joue le coup à cette assise dans la
mesure d'abord acculée la dame
la dame doit partir peut-être sur la
classe c 4 qui maintient la taxe sur le
pion pour garder la pression sur ce pion
mais c'est une fausse pression peut
jouer par exemple b6
très tranquillement suite fou bessette
et les pièces noires sont sur des postes
très importants
garry kasparov nous fait le coup des
boutons des boutons il a il remet les
boutons de sa chemise
en général il a beaucoup de difficulté à
le faire c'est mettre un mixage de
calais 17 ya pas deux il n'y a pas photo
il n'y a pas de bluff nous ceci dit pour
la première fois chronique avec pas les
uns forcément à vis d'eux du coup de
kasparov il restait à l'échiquier il a
réfléchi un peu oui bah c'est surprenant
un coup comme d'amd 5 c'est à dire que
les joueurs enfin ça a l'air tellement
peu fondées que cram leak a du mal à se
dire que c'est kasparov qui vient de
lever ce coup dans un match au
championnat du monde dames b5 damas cap
celui d'amd 5
honnêtement c'est très très inattendu le
calligramme nick est passé de d5 en 17
on va revenir sur la position des
joueurs actuellement voilà c'est ça le
cavalier de vladimir kramnik alors
attention c c'est comme ça voilà le kite
chronique était en d5
il est reparti sur la case 17 mai
kasparov lui à une dame mal placé
maintenant
mais rien ne dit que le cavalier soit
mendiants 17 condé fin puisque on
descend qu'il était en crise et un peu
sous pression du fou j'ai 2 par exemple
éduquer c'est rodez satie n'obstrue un
peu le fossé 8
c'est vrai ce que kasparov a pas obtenu
une position obscurs comme il les aime
avec beaucoup de pièces vont peut-être
ça lui a coûté cher
dames en bessin cap à l'est avec une
splendide mais on est pour l'instant la
position est passé obscur c'est ont pu
très vite retomber dans les et sortent
des taux de maroc 6 0 parce que les
pièces marc sont bien placés pour jouer
saronique jouer s'il ya eu 7 5 mais il
n'est pas pressé de le jouer puisque ça
vous retrouverez les régionales de son
fou et ça donnerait la casse des cinq
une fois pour toutes
ouais c'est vrai aux pièces blanches là
pour l'instant kasparov a quand même un
problème au centre puisque pour
l'instant il n'a pas bougé section du
centre
c'est totalement inhabituel non mais ici
on sent que kasparov et quand même sur
un terrain où il n'a pas envie d'être
puisqu'il n'a pas joué le 4 il n'a pas
joué de coups violents
spo rouen se joue un petit peu bout
peut-être joué moule a fait gagner le
championnat du monde à séville en 87
quand même même avec une rétine et la
dernière ils ont aidé anglaise des
répits d'ouverture qui ont pas l'air
d'être son style mais s'il en fait
quelque chose
ouais m'enfin là contre chronique c'est
pas forcément un très bon choix ça
n'était pas non plus forcément contre
karpov a priori mais ça avait bien
marché mais krainik à mon avis ici et
quand même motivé là un superbe plan sur
garry kasparov très très concentré car
ils ne bougent plus c'est une vraie
statue grecque qui arménienne vivant une
statue arménienne plus tôt puisque
rappelons que tu es également arménien à
moitié la moitié arménien la galerie est
en pleine réflexion
alors petit rappel nous sommes ici à
londres rider studio en direct garry
kasparov numéro un mondiale championne
monde depuis 15 ans joue le challenger
vladimir kramnik 24 ans le petit jeune
son ancien élève son ancien seconde en
est aux commentaires nous avons jérôme
cela qui en est le brand et loire
revanche est le grand maître et le var
l'enjeu c'est à dire moi même voix la d2
d3
garry kasparov vraiment est très très
léger dans cette partie il joue vraiment
des coups vraiment mais vraiment jérôme
qui n'ont pas l'air menaçant
est-ce que c'est du kasparov
ça ressemble plutôt à une partie que je
ne nommerai pas partie digne
des plus grands cafés parisiens des
parisiens auraient tout à fait on peut
mentionner le cloître
voilà un lieu avec des spécialistes de
l'anglais mais enfin on ne pensait pas
que kasparov irait jusqu'à jouer ça tout
à fait des 3 si on peut voir la position
ça a vraiment l'air complètement
surprenant garry kasparov très très lent
joue une sorte de sicilienne dragon vous
voyez la formation du dragon ici mais
avec les blancs ça s'appelle en fait une
anglaise éclats d'âme en bessin avec la
dame en bessin c'est l'élément
surprenant de cette condition chronique
alors lui il très très tranquille dans
cette position il joue petit rock petit
rock avec le sourire il n'est pas pressé
d'attaquer la dame en bessin qu il reste
souple et il l'attaquera quand il voudra
de toute façon la dame ne restera pas là
puisque cette case est vraiment trop
minable on retrouve parfois la dame sur
ce genre de cadre des escales indiennes
la dame noire en général
la dame noire dans ce désastre indienne
g3 quand je vous dis le plan avec dame
b3 et d'imbécile cependant estimé 4 pour
attaquer le pont le pion c'est vrai
lancé quatre essais varela l'idée un peu
la même de mettre les pièces adverse sur
des cases bizarre sauf que c'est pas
tout à fait ça quand même un mail à
l'actif kasparov
vraiment on ne voit pas la pointe des
coups qu'il est en train de jouer on va
lui non plus apparemment lui non plus le
vide
willem ne verrait pas ce qui se passe
mais leur attention parce qu on avance
souvent tendance à se tromper qu a
cependant fait une tête tellement
d'enfer fouet trois ça ils attaquent
l'option ils attaquent l'option ces cinq
bons pour 3 pourquoi pas alors est-ce
qu'on peut pas jouer des groupes comme
comme cavalier des quatre peut-être qui
est des cats à 100 visages tels iossif
dorfman c'est la spécialité du aussi
fait j'étais très friands du cou qui
avait laissé six cent des cas ceux-ci
leur french entrant 98 ex seconde ans et
entraîneur de garry kasparov pour le
match de moscou 84
qui est donc un spécialiste de cook a
laissé six ans des quatre alors on va
peut-être regarder la position
maintenant voilà voilà
le coût possible de vladimir kramnik
avec des cartes je ne pense pas qu'il ne
qu'il va jouer qu'il va choisir ce coup
je le verrais mieux choisir à 6 pub et
si ce qui al'air peut-être plus
positionnelle mais qu'ils avaient des
cats quand même ça sans visage jérôme
ici que peut jouer
garry kasparov a priori pas grand chose
pas grand chose si ce n'est fou prend
des cartes mais peut-être là peut-être
dame c4 alors de la capitale blaya
cavaliers pros avec trois cavaliers 101
exactement on va le mentionner d'hamsik
at il n'ya cavaliers prend cavaliers
échec au roi
on reprend du fou c'est très logique a
classé la structure est maintenant
cavalier e 5 et n'ont regagné la paire
de fond pourquoi sacrifier un pion mais
y gagne
faut il garder la structure blanche si
les gens nous disent ils et blanc jouent
d'un procès cinq cavaliers pros avec
trois échecs
non il est tout à fait d'hommes france
est simple on va prendre en f3 avec
échec et une très belle position pour
les noirs et organes peut-être même en
vivant des trois lots médiatement en d3
donc ici vraisemblablement les blanches
jouer un coup comme d'amérique après
après calais pour un f3 dames 3 3 les ça
serait un net avantage pour les voir
pourquoi bien à cause de la paire de
foot c'était bien de fou contre un fou
et un cavalier dans le camp des blancs
ça s'appelle l' avantage la paire de
fouet travnik évidemment en serait très
satisfait donc sûr qu'il y ait des
quatre le coup dans cette position là et
bien il semblerait que la blanche en
bessin kasparov ne puisse pas jouer dans
ces cas ne puisse pas jouer grand chose
et s'il joue fou prend des 4 et bien
après puis on prend les quatre nocifs
dorfman serait aux anges puisque ici il
aurait 1 puis en d4 la paire de fond un
pion bien avancé la paire de fou et
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à échanger
les dames comme il le dit lui-même après
cavaliers ou quatre on pourra jouer d'un
v6 très simplement avec une très très
belle position donc à vue garry kasparov
et bien revenons sur la position telle
qu'elle est actuellement
rex sur l'écran brutaux dans ses selles
n'a bladimir crâne et peut jouer qu'à
les d4 va peut-être le faire a noté
évidemment que sur qui est des cartes
sim blanc ne valent pas donné la peur de
fou mais prendre quand même en d4 sa
chair
inconvénient majeur c'est qu'après si on
prend des quatre il ya ce que l'on
appelle une fourchette 0 me et oui c'est
vrai qu'on peut garder la perte de fond
et c'est une pièce de moi ça coûte une
pièce si on veut prendre des cartes
quand même
ce n'est pas une bonne chose cavaliers
des quatre voies la chronique à ce coup
là parmi sa panoplie de possibilités qui
a l'air de bien correspondre à son style
avec les noirs qui assèche à ses juges
bien les positions
oui c'est vrai que cela aurait le mérite
en plus d'autres faire quelques échanges
ici tu as part of jouerait probablement
le coût d'un ak je pense ça paraît quand
même assez logique
voilà très beaux plans sur vladimir
kramnik mais de nouveau un plan sur
l'échiquier démonstration avec damas
quatre coups très logique sur quoi l'an
la recommandation de l'ordinateur qui va
vous surprendre qui nous surprend tout
ce qui nous surprend toujours le coup
bessette b5 et bon bond impressionnant
apparemment sur cavaliers prend b5
il y a une pointe il est un point final
au pion aux 220 ans qu'on va prendre
deux salles à un peu ses effets qui vont
acquérir et peut-être l'autre idée c'est
que si les blancs occupent la dame
chasser le cavalier ces trois peut-être
mais bon ça a l'air un peu blanche ou
d'âme des uns ici je pense qu'on
développera les pièces va faire
attention à au point tactiques quand
même le faire on à la pj la grande
diagonale effectivement le discret 2
tape violemment sur la tour invite donc
ici il faut jouer le coup de tourbe et
vite c'est possible c'est bien dans le
point des noirs alors la cram nick va
peut-être jouer qu'à valider 4 il est
certainement en train de le considérer
alors jérôme avec stéphane laborde
on se demandait ce que pensait vladimir
kramnik quand on voyait sa tête est là
est ce que toi qui est donc qui joue
régulièrement au poker peut nous dire ce
que pensent de la demi-heure karnik en
tout cas nous ne vont pas aussi à lire
son visage impassible
si je savais ce qu'il pense j'aurais
probablement 300 points elo de plus donc
rappelons quand même que tu as 2350 même
pas absolue on réglait enfin en tout cas
un bon joueur international
il a l'air très calme en tout cas pas
impressionner par kasparov comme
d'habitude
garry kasparov rappelons qu'il avait
embauché vladimir kramnik pour être son
second temps aux 95 peut-être que ça lui
coûte cher
peut-être que là il va s'apercevoir que
c'était pas forcément la meilleure
décision qu'il est prise effectivement
vous l'avenir cramique a l'air très très
tranquille et on se demande vraiment ce
que garry kasparov a prévu pourquoi
carrick est ce qu'on en fait jouer ça
c'est la grande inconnue
ça
alors que stéphane laborde va revenir
pour faire des commentaires
donc jérôme je vais te laisser avec la
star de diagonale première longue
réflexion de crown hic il faut enlever
la chasse pour l'instant pour laisser
rentrer le commentateur étoiles
stéphane laborde pas si simple chronique
bien concentrés pour la première fois
sur les sites de démonstration si on
peut le revoir
voilà la position actuelle qu'on les
deux joueurs et donc le coût envisagé
probablement par kramix aurait le coup
cavaliers c6 sur la case des quatre pas
aussi bon voilà qu'elle sait si sur la
place des quatre ici contre attaques
quand la dame et posant des problèmes
aux blancs tentant d'échanger quelques
pièces et utilisant directement
l'américain sorte en d4
il y en a même passion bon les noirs
peuvent aussi jouer le plan que
conseiller et loi c'est-à-dire repousser
la dame avec à 6 6 me ont été
effectivement un coup à 7 à 6 pour jouer
ensuite bessaih prend peut-être ou b 6
selon le seul endroit où baldam baissé
ce qui tient une fois et ensuite avant
qu'ils ont poussé ce plan soit d'une
case soit 2,2 selon le choix des blancs
si les blancs jouent des amas 4 on peut
bien sûr la joue et b6 puisque le cas au
lycée ci serait en l'air donc peut-être
qu'on jouerait bessan et qui est fou et
et encore une fois on a l'impression que
chronique à trouver de quoi embêter
kasparov brouilly réfléchi quand même
l'appli fissures lanka les d4 ici qu'il
a une possibilité de d'augmenter la
capacité de sa position qui à l'encré
mixer sur l' otan donc kasparov a
utilisé une demi-heure contre 24 minutes
akram unique tous les cas une position
inattendue on se demandait avant la
partie à quoi on aurait droit à une
écossaise peut-être à nouveau une
effectivement peut-être parce qu'on
regarde l'écossaise comme marc secrète
mais il est probable que chronique soit
extrêmement bien préparées sur
l'écossaise puisque travnikis revenu à
cavalier c6 alors qu'il s'est plutôt un
joueur de petrov avec deux cavaliers
apsys donc on peut supposer qu'il a une
en préparation sur l'écossaise que
kasparov s'est refusé à jouer jusqu'ici
effectivement on a trouvé la défense
berlinoise tour contre l'espagnol parce
qu'il sait très bien que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut aussi jouer l'espagnol et il a
sûrement préparé quelque chose sur
l'écossaise donc pour l'instant c'est
plutôt kasparov qui est contré dans ses
ouvertures plutôt qu'aux kramnik ce qui
est assez rare effectivement il était un
peu arrivé avec un land en 95 au début
du match ce qu'il a eu pas mal de
problèmes sur sa nage d'or favorites ont
essayé c'est là qu'on a vu la souplesse
du jeu de kasparov puisqu'ils et en
quelques jours il est passé à dragon qui
est une autre une autre système très
complexe et donc il a joué avec de très
bons résultats contre mai à nombre ce
championnat du monde avec deux sur trois
même deux ans et demi sur trois avec les
noirs c'est énorme ce qu'ils étaient
dans bien sûr qui prouve qu'il peut
changer rapidement début et que c'est
vraiment ce joint forme mais là il
permet pas de jouer la dragon tonton
cramique qui jouent des quatre voilà
régulièrement creux je crois que rami
qui a joué 4 dans un match exhibition
j'avais pas longtemps mais contre
kasparov on n'y croit pas tellement les
résultats kasparov a tellement tellement
fort avec sur vega de l'âge d'or ouais
même karpov qui je voyais 4 assez
régulièrement une époque et passer à
d'autres à d'autres schémas d'ouverture
contre kasparov donc vraiment ça serait
pas le style ça c'est pas le style et
puis surtout ça rentre pas dans ils ne
voient pas pourquoi ils changeraient
telle position avec les blancs pour le
moment et oui il a tellement bien
choisissez zoug
autre à munich quelle star of qui doit
encore tout prouvé dans l'ombre mais
peut-être alors dans la durée du match
c'est là où le match la durée du match
très important dans ma radio match qu'à
sport peut trouver des solutions peut
trouver des solutions pour contrer
kramnik sur les ouvertures qu'il a
choisi et le forcer à revenir
éventuellement dans les ouvertures que
kasparov à lui préparé kasparov et en
plus habitué aux matches longs ce qui
n'est pas le cas de crimes dit
effectivement chronique peut manquer
d'expérience à il a l'air un petit peu
embêté cramique la mal-apposition donald
r un petit peu embêté donc ils sévissent
et forcément ce qu'on peut jouer dans
cette position mais il est en train de
se demander si que kasparov a pu
préparer
est ce que c'est un piège que mme ottan
kasparov ou pas est-ce que je peux jouer
qu'à les d4 ou pas il va choisir quand
même on a l'impression qu'on est sorti
quand même assez rapidement des
répertoires d'ouverture puisque les deux
joueurs ont presque la place une
demi-heure 11e couleurs que normalement
les premiers coups son défilé assez vite
et là on joue on joue tout de suite vous
pose des problèmes très rapidement je
pense que vous peut être pas si mal pour
kasparov pour la première fois la
position et la complexe assez rapidement
peut-être que moi mais c'est sûrement le
problème kasparov cesser
encore une fois c'est pas la fin il aime
bien les positions complexes c'est sûr
mais il aime surtout et dans des
préparations à lui ne craint ni client
n'est ce pas l'occasion c'est ça son
problème principal pour le moment pour
le moment il est coincé
kasparov ils n'arrivent pas à forcer
kramnik à rentrer dans ses préparations
sinon avec la ville où on n'a pas
l'impression kasparov encore en
préparation où il a déjà deux mille ans
à la fin du mois un mois qu'ils fassent
ils fassent semblant mais la team love
caspar ans comme il sait faire des
grimaces de la filière il ya encore en
préparation pour 15 coups et qui j'ai
l'impression qu'on va encore avoir droit
à une partie sanglante aujourd'hui
j'espère maintenant le combat est pas
tout à fait lancée actuellement dans la
préparation des pièces dans la
préparation de la position mais il ya
déjà quand même des vrais choix à faire
oui la tient déjà un riche allait faire
ses vrais choix de position les morts
peuvent jouer ou des schémas avec cassis
et b6 ou bessan comme étant le sien ou
le front ancien ghetto où vous essayez
de d'échanger les pièces effectivement
lequel des quatre qui change
complètement radicalement tout de suite
l'instruction la position laisse rêveur
et l'audition est des vrais choix à
faire des dès les premiers coups c'est
que ça c'est intéressant
l'impression qu'avec des 4 as l'air
quand même un coût assez fort en tout
cas c'est le goût proposé par la machine
l'ordinateur propose de coupler des 4
propose aussi le coup assiste donc c'est
les deux options me concentrer les plus
ça laisse supposer que les choses sont
peut-être pas si simple dans cette
position il a l'air un peu moins détendu
que depuis hier
non mais c'est clair que là pour que si
travelling ne veut pas il n'a pas
d'autre coup tellement intéressante à 6
ou clavier de d4 de toute façon le fou
s'est vite pour l'instant et bloquer les
tours n'ont pas de classe d' intéressant
toile et donc il faut avoir un faut
prendre un peu d'air
donc soit cavale et des quatre soit à 6
ont l'air d'être les seuls coûts donc il
va jouer forcément kramnik le coup à 7
ans assis si on peut vous montrer
l'échiquier de démonstration ou le coup
cavale et c6 en d4
voilà les deux coups qui sont avides des
flèches le coût du pion qui attaquent la
dame où le coût du cavalier katakana en
tout cas chroniques va donc attaquer la
dame de kasparov au prochain coup c'est
quasiment suivant il n'y a pas d'autres
coups intéressants
- est-ce que peut-être il peut essayer
d'échanger les dames avec dame bézis sa
spécialité dans le match pour le moment
madame b 6 les changer d'armé sur d'un
pro b si ça prend des six mois mais il
n'a pas peur que ce soit devant le promu
6 puisque si les noirs prennent des
cavaliers qui reprend on peut créer des
problèmes à la torah 8 peut-être ans et
7 ans jouant comme on voit en cavale et
c7 ensuite peut-être je sais pas
pour pas de brosser possibilités sont
possibilités
en mai 2006 et pas trop dans le
tempérament du trafic ça pourrait
m'arriver kasparov mais changer d'avis
une fois de plus
bon bien sûr que ce sport fait projet
d'échangé les dames il pleuvait surtout
près d'am prendre à mon mètre obligé de
reprendre du pillon est ce que c'est que
si on prend une curieuse père le pion c5
et si on reprend du pied on laisse les
classes b 5 très affaibli voyons la
possibilité par exemple crainte de faire
d'un v6 je pense que dans ce cas là
qu'elle reprendrait sans hésiter on peut
pas reprendre du cavalier ici scoop par
le public on perd le pion csn qui est
attaqué par le fou 3 donc il faut
reprendre du pian et là on voit que la
case b5 ici est très faible et donc un
cavalier ici sera excellemment bien
placé alors que le mot blog la case b4
ici peut être contrôlée par les blancs
par le cou à 2 à 3 donc la salle ferait
probablement une petite concession ou
blanc et en plus eu peut-être une petite
faiblesse mois avec ses deux pions
doublé l'acronyme n'a peut-être pas
intérêt à faire ça
d'autant plus que kasparov n'est pas
obligé dé change évidemment en plus
kasparov vous serez pas obligés de les
changer d'âme donc ça c'est pas un coût
qui pose de gros problèmes aux blancs
donc peut-être plutôt contraire le
bouquet des quatre où le coup à six en
tout cas posent des questions et gagner
un peu d espace donc on l'air en plus
d'un dans l'esprit de position
à
pense tranquillement évidemment le temps
va jouer encore une fois dans cette
partie des joueurs utilisés quasiment
une demi heure pour jouer leurs 11
premiers coups ils sont donc à peu près
dans la bonne cadence -une complètement
puisque les souvent les les coûts du 20e
et 30e sont quand même
et quand il demande beaucoup de
réflexion de ce qu'ils on critique donc
en général des jouets du premier coup un
peu plus vite c'est vrai donc là on vous
rappelle que le temps qui est utilisé
dans ce championnat du monde et de deux
heures pour chaque joueur au début de la
partie
ils ont deux heures pour atteindre le
40e coup deux heures chacun delà du 40e
coup ils ont une heure supplémentaire
qui leur est alloué et hier on est allé
même au delà du soixantième coup ou là
on rajoute une demi heure à chaque
joueur pour terminer la partie
une demi heure et dix secondes de
parcours la dengue est g nick est pas un
peu moins seringue habitudes voyez il
n'a pas l'air mais disons que la
position est très compliqué tout de
suite je pense que les deux joueurs de
toute façon hors or préparation de ce
match n'est pas de grande grande
préparation dans cette partie en tout
cas puisque pour le reste on peut leur
faire confiance
voilà donc là je pense que là il
réfléchit tout simplement plein qui va
employer ne reste que kasparov et ainsi
on ne voit pas là sur ce plan ce qui est
un peu étonnant sur puma du monde ce
qu'on a vu hier c'est que les joueurs
sont vraiment rarement un site on sait
pas jouer
oui même nom qui sont rarement deux face
à face mais ils ont là sauf dans les
moments vraiment critique comme pour les
gens qui ont vu la partie d'hier au
moment de fou prend 1,6 quand la
tactique a commencé et qu'elle les deux
joueurs avaient un peu moins de temps
mais sinon les joueurs sont vraiment
assez peu façon dont les championnats du
monde précédent c'était quand même moins
le cas je me souviens d'ailleurs je vous
rappel vous pouvez voir les meilleurs
moments d'hier en vidéo puisque en
dessous de l'applet à votre droite vous
avez des fichiers vidéos qui sont votre
disposition qui sont les monédières donc
vous avez le résumé de la partie
la conférence de presse et les meilleurs
moments de la partie d'hier avec
notamment le commentaire sur fou prend
1,6 tu nous disais jérôme kasparov qui
ceint un peu plein et qui avait l'air
vraiment perturbé par ce coup oui tout à
fait ça me plains pas ce qu'on avait
fait un peu de bruit et effectivement
elle se casse pas c'est un peu drôle qui
se plaignent à ce moment là aussi cac 40
ouais ouais ça devient difficile pour
lui c'est vrai et puis
vous pouvez cliquer aussi dans le bouton
archives vidéo pour voir tous les
préserver du mes précédents ainsi toutes
les émissions de diagonale qui ont été
enregistrés depuis deux ans avec
notamment la retransmission des grands
prix de bordeaux du sénat et du match
etienne bacrot contre judit polgar des
grands prix de parties rapides avec 20
minutes par joueur et deux grand nombre
puisque michael adams avait gagné à
bordeaux
alexei shirov avait gagné au sénat et
tous ces moments sont en vidéo à la
demande dans les archives de diagonale
profitez-en si vous n'avez pas vu la
partie d'hier ça vaut vraiment le coup
ah oui mais peu importe idiart font
regarder les meilleurs moments de la
partie une partie avec des
rebondissements des erreurs ouais un
rare quand même pour des joueurs de ce
niveau on alors presque cramique aurait
dû gagner facilement cette finale
effectivement kasparov qui a trouvé des
ressources défensive incroyable vraiment
une partie je pense qu'il va rester
c'est vrai c'était soit l'issue c'est un
grand moment de cette première semaine
là on peut estimer que randall un
deuxième semaine puisque donc le match a
démarré dimanche dernier
donc on est rentré dans la deuxième
semaine de ce match les quatre premières
parties ont été jouées et à la fin de
cette semaine on aura déjà fait la
moitié du match on préfère un premier
bilan pour l'instant avantage cramique
l'est peut-être psychologiquement il ya
un peu moins fort après cette partie
d'hier où c'est vrai qu'il a très bien
joué le début oui mais non c'est pas sûr
qu'il soit un peu moins fort parce que
classement qui n'a pas vraiment de
trouver de meilleurs quand même retourné
une partie incroyable pendant que les
castors devrait toujours le problème de
quoi jouer avec les noirs contre
chronique parce que je dois aussi
d'ailleurs avec les blancs aussi mais
peut-être un peu moins aujourd'hui il a
trouvé quelque chose en tout cas qu'à
l'air mais aussi vrai qu'il n'a pas
réussi à passer la berlinoise de
chroniques et donc ils n'arrivent pas à
imposer son jugement à imposer ses choix
cramique et ça c'est très important
la suite du match kramnik en réflexion
maintenant depuis
presque dix minutes pour réfléchir à un
coût qui peut être crucial le coup
cavaliers des quatre tremblements peut
regarder cavaliers des 15 quelles sont
les options des blancs alors après si on
demande chic et démonstrations on va
vous montrer actuellement la position et
celle ci et là les noirs pourrait jouer
c'est ce que réfléchir à munich qu'à
valider 4 et d'ailleurs il joue cavalier
des 4 il a joué cahier des quatre mais
voilà donc mon nom ont montré cette
possibilité kramnik vient de jouer le
coup câbles et des 4 et encore une fois
mais le feu à l'échiquier alors les
couples en les couplant et mais
semble-t-il de l'ordinateur ne propose
pas autre chose que fout prendre les
quatre dom c4 voilà on peut peut-être
aussi jouer d'un mac avec un petit
avantage noir qu'on signale l'ordinateur
tout de suite il semblerait que les
noirs est un petit avantage centrale
notamment ici possibilité pour les
blancs soit prendre en d4 se jouer la
dame b 5 sur la case c4 peut-être
peut-être damas quatre aussi à vérifier
dans vingt quatre valère d'être réfutées
par le groupe de cette baisse inc
peut-être pas si clair
en fait moi
on va le gérer non jérôme exactement
merci j'ai pour ces commentaires pouvoir
regarder l'autre et on peut très bien
avec éloi et oui c'était femmes cette
superbe chronicles a fait craquements
café et oui je vais dire les 4 et la
casse par an et encore une fois dans la
boîte on a une pression j'ai or
préparation je viens de croiser vladimir
kramnik qui m'a fait un grand sourire
avant d'aller aux toilettes justement
ouais ouais ouais tout à fait il a l'air
très contente de sa position ohlala
il a l'air serein kramnik et donc
chronique qui va aux toilettes
tranquillement sans avoir peur qu'avant
cramique avait peur d'aller aux
toilettes puisque kramnik qu'on appelle
à perdre a peur du noir et que les
petits problèmes de micros on a le
matériel qui semble-t-il est qu'ils nous
lâchent mais ce n'est pas grave puisque
nous avons ce qui tout un tas de micro
de remplacement d'éric laporte je vous
prends des câpres et oui je n'avais pas
le choix ils n'avaient pas le choix
s'ils pouvaient jouer dame c4 aussi
semble-t-il mais mais c'était choisir
vos graines et encore une fois cramique
force kasparov a donné sa paire de fou
tout à fait hélas après krainik va bien
entendu jouer s'éprend des 4 1 mais
cramique a choisi d ouverture qui oblige
kasparov a donné sa paire de fou et ça
aussi bien qu'à ce prix là alors la
regardons bien qu'elle va maintenant lui
proposer un grand classique dans ce
match nous propose l échange des dames
stéphane dans bliss va jouer aux
imbéciles c'est très probable c'est le
bon coup dans cette position et après
l'échangé dame est ce que les noirs ont
repeint un tout petit avantage du à la
paire de fou il semblerait que les noirs
soit un petit peu mieux oh lalala lalala
kramnik encore une fois pose des
problèmes à kasparov cavaliers ou 4 il a
l'air tranquille cramique oh là là
quelle sérénité et c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable ce qui est en train de
se passer on vit probablement match
historique kramnik dans ce début de
match montre
qu'il a la carrure d'un futur champion
du monde
il n'a pas le charisme d'un kasparov ça
c'est une certitude le charisme ne fait
pas le joueur
c'est vrai faut rappeler que un joueur
comme boat chimiques n'avait pas
forcément non plus un très grand
charisme
oui mais même sur l'échiquier d'ailleurs
les grands champions dont on se rappelle
c'est évidemment bobby fischer série
zone lennox lewis
tous ces champions qui sont donc très
charismatique qui c'est vrai voire même
un peu fou vladimir kramnik a l'air très
stable très équilibré très serein il n'a
a priori pas la carrure pas la stature
d'un champion du monde
et pourtant il en a le talent puisqu'ici
il est en train de miner garry kasparov
facilement avec les noirs dans une
anglaise symétrique il va probablement
jouer d'un v6 proposer l'échangé d'un
mac askarov une fois de plus dans ce
match est en finale on sait que cram
nique et redoutable qui ne fait
pratiquement pas d'erreur ici il a l'air
de s'être bien remis en fait en tout cas
de sa semi défaite d'hier soir défaite
psychologique
non mais il est peut-être pas si
mécontent que ça il c'est vrai que le
fait pour trouver le coup gagnant 2,30 g
8 qui était pas si évident que ça après
un avis finalement été gagnant c'est
clair mais pas si évident que ça à voir
comme un gagnant d'autant plus qu'il est
resté quelque chose qu'on trois ou
quatre minutes akram unique pour le
trouver sur le coup tout à fait
pas évident il soit vraiment mécontent
de sa partie d'hier il appelant quand
même dominé kasparov et karpov s'en est
sorti de justesse du peut-être content
quand même puisque kasparov va toujours
avoir le même problème que jouer avec
les noirs contre kramnik puisqu'à chaque
fois il se fait proprement balayé de
l'échiquier il à g nique en grande
réflexion
pour jouer probablement l'option dame b6
pourquoi parce que les noirs peuvent
échanger les dames avec un avantage
certain
ils auront la paire de fou et ça c'est
toujours un avantage en finale d'autant
plus que la position va pouvoir s'ouvrir
à tout moment les noirs ayant des
possibilités de jouer des ruptures de
pions et donc de mettre le feu
l'échiquier encore une fois kramnik est
en train de dominer kasparov dans sa
préparation
le champion du monde kasparov n'arrive
pas à contrer vladimir kramnik dans les
ouvertures et à lui-même posé ses choix
chronique va probablement jouer le
ku'damm b6 qui a l'air d'être un
excellent coup qui propose d'échanger
dames et obtient une position au moins
égal voilà la position actuelle de
l'échiquier cramique va proposer
à kasparov les charges des dames avec le
coup montrer ici en verre d'amd 8 vient
sur la case b6 et les blancs n'ont pas
trop le choix puisque si la dame bouge
le pion b2 et emprise de la dame noire
donc il faut échanger les dames et après
cet échange de dan kramnik reprend du
cavalier et a tout de suite
une position qui semble avantageuse au
moins égale kramnik a déjà égalisé et
peut-être même pris une option pour
l'initiative dans ce match dans cette
partie
d'autres options akrami qui peut aussi
jouer d'autres coups comme cavalier b6
rien ne presse pour lui ici il réfléchit
tranquillement à ses possibilités au
niveau du temps kramnik à utiliser 40
minutes contre 33 à kasparov
donc c'est sensiblement égal
est encore en train de réfléchir il va
probablement jouer le coup d'amd 6 on
sent qu'il va le faire on sent qu'ils
veulent faire stéphane ses passions il
peut aussi garder les dames il n'y a pas
eu tout cas l'avantagé kramix et qu'il a
démontrées kasparov qu'il est à l'aise
aussi lui aussi dans les complications
et que donc il n'hésitera pas à se
lancer sur le terrain de kasparov en
tout cas chroniques et surtout très
enfin peut-être que cramique va essayer
de jouer sur les points faibles de
kasparov et pour l'instant kasparov a
montré que quand c'était compliqué il
s'en sortait plutôt bien quand il se
fait vis et simplement
eh bien il se fait vie c'est simplement
justement effectivement non peut-être
qu'il a joué dans bay 6 pour le vix
s'est tranquillement et profité d'un
pique un petit avantage
voilà voilà les apc où il a joué
d'imbéciles a là aucun bluff crânien est
encore en train de vie c'est kasparov
qui va être obligé de prendre les dames
c'est aussi obliger à eloyes n'y a pas
d'autre n'a pas d'autre recours que d'en
prendre six puisque le pion b2 et
emprise c'est l'autre coup envisageable
si on veut pas changer d'âme c'est à 2 à
4 non mais ça sert de l'a4 dame panda
mais on prend du purement avec des pions
doublé c'est l'horreur à 2 400 visage
quand même il faut pas non plus aussi
envisageable puisque on garderait une
pression mais la tour 1 sur le pion à
cette petite pression qui peut s'avérer
désagréable d'ailleurs je verrais bien
qu'il espère jouer à 2 à 4 ça a pas
l'air ridicule du tout oui de l'a4 à
l'air envisageable mais kramnik pour
jouer sur la doua 4 à 7 à 6 peut-être
ouais mais selon la dame prend cavaliers
alors on va vous le montrez d'un
programme une simulation kramnik vient
de jouer d'amd si ça c'est sûr
sika sport joue à 4 donc sa chique et
démonstrations après sur dame pro b 5
puis on prend bessin non non on en a
joué à ce jeu c'est possible à 6 tout de
suite ici nous allons pointé la colonne
à voile à la tour ici à une action sur
le sur le pion à 7
voilà donc ici sur d'assura quatre
probablement le coup à 7 à 6 voilà c'est
aussi tout simplement et là il faut
prendre la dame
il faut prendre la dame qui avait lié
prend car il prend mais maintenant les
blancs ont une possibilité
supplémentaire ils peuvent
fixez les pions de vladimir kramnik et
après qu'est et d5 jouait le coup qui a
blessé cinq et la position deviendra
extrêmement complexe oui parce que là le
cavalier fait pression sur bessette et
le quadrillage 3d qui joue ouvre le fou
j'ai deux sur la grande diagonale
ici ça serait assez chaud
vraisemblablement garry kasparov va
jouer ce coup à 2 à 4 c'est très
probable à moins qu'il envisage de jouer
peut-être dame prend b6 tout de suite et
sur cavani prend le coup à quatre ça
c'est possible également mais c'est
moins probable garry kasparov en pleine
réflexion l'aïd est comment dire
tapie sur le sur la table de jeu ah oui
là il est allongé sur l'échiquier train
de dormir un peu car il faut dire que la
position d'hier la partie d'hier était
très tendue les joueurs sont ce
probablement très fatigué ce match
eloi même cour avec le rythme de parti
qui est imposée au joueur risque de
s'avérer très fatigante pour les joueurs
rappeler que le rythme habituel qu'on
avait pour les parties de 24 parties je
crois que c'était plutôt de trois
parties par semaine et non pas quatre
effectivement c'était trois parties par
semaine c'était des matchs donc qui doit
longtemps un mois et demi c'était plus
long là quatre parties par semaine c'est
très éprouvant pour les joueurs et
notamment deux parties consécutives
c'est très très difficile normalement ça
ne se fait pas hélas le championnat du
monde plus court mais en fait plus sport
+ sport plus tendue au niveau des nerfs
au niveau de la résistance psychique des
joueurs psychologique
alors là kasparov embêter encore une
fois par le biais de chroniques mais il
va trouver quelque chose
il ya probablement encore un petit
avantage kasparov je ne sais pas dans
cette position
oui en quoi malgré des sports se
retrouver proprement moi bien montrer
tel coup avec les blancs ça paraît très
improbable mais c'est néanmoins possible
ici cramique à la peur de fou on connaît
le talent de vladimir kramnik à faire
passer les initiatives et demi à la
transférer en à la transposer en riant
il arrive très facilement à neutraliser
un placement de pièces supérieure de son
adversaire et l'altérité sport doit donc
jouer très très précis doit convertir
immédiatement sa petite avance au
développement puisque si on regarde bien
on voit que dans la pression réelle
voilà garry kasparov a quand même alors
des pièces mieux développer comme
l'admirent chronique est parfois comme
un bon plan c'est que le fou j'ai dit
oui tout de suite venir sont notables
voilà le pouget de tap
ici on va montrer à 2 à 4 à 2 voilà bien
joué bien jouer gary n 24
bien joué garry kasparov garry kasparov
dans cette position a clairement
l'initiative
il a une petite initiative des parents
finissent est signé à doha qat l'idée
c'est que si les noirs prennent
évidemment la tour 1 est tout de suite
et dans le jeu et la cahc soir va se
régaler parce que pour une fois il va
avoir le petit initiatives pour lui et
ça entre les mains de kasparov
ça fait souvent mouche donc il faut que
la lumière se fasse très attention
oui mais enfin attention parce que dans
les dents toutes les ouvertures où il a
joué aux quatre les deux premières
parties où les blancs il a eu
l'initiative mais finalement kramix on
est très très bien tiré donc ramené qui
est un excellent défenseur également
donc que se passe-t-il que raconte la
fable quand les paie la plus tranchante
du monde a rencontré le bouclier le plus
solides du monde que c'était passé
stéphane vinet je sais pas eh bien ils
se sont cassé tous les deux tout
simplement donc parties nulles à prévoir
c'était effectivement en chine que cela
s'est produit à 2 à 4 vient d'être jouée
ici à londres versailles studio en l'an
2000 c'est donc le moderne mais en tout
cas c'est prenant le meilleur attaquant
contre le meilleur défenseur que plus
chevelu cramique est actuellement est
bien comment on peut prendre la dame
c'est une possibilité en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est une chronique a envie de
trouver une case sympathique % kelly 17
ici en guerre pour pouvoir sortir sont
fous ces mythes et ensuite mettre la
tour en jeu sur la colonne cette colonne
ci qui est l'enjeu de cette position
effectivement c'est là toute la
difficulté du problème
oui parce que je crois que jouer
cavalier ou 5 stéphane dans cette
position ça a l'air d'être un coup
peut-être pas si mal mais ce n'est pas
un sujet valère donc à lieusaint coeur
de parc de pyong des quatre noms ça a
l'air de faire le point des quatre oui
mais ça ne le perd pas en fait ça peut
faire peur mais bon c'est pas parfait un
castrat aussi un plan il a un plan
kasparov il peut jouer tour c'est un
d'un programme et 11,7 et tour cessé et
qui se trouve à mettre la pression sur
les pions blancs et notamment le pion
bessette notamment une option mais cette
qui ont fait cette musique que ce pion
est aussi sous le feu du fou g2 est donc
pression blanche évidente dans cette
partie 1 kasparov pas qu'il ait besoin
de même très fort erie kasparov a fait
mais une petite pression dans le camp
des noirs mais la chronique va sûrement
trouver une idée c'est quand même
incroyable caspar fille june anglaise
une ouverture qui n'a l'air de rien
position symétrique et il arrive à
trouver des choses enfin faut dire que
les deux joueurs sont surprenants les
deux joueurs avec les gens arrivent à
trouver des chances impressionnante
arrive à trouver des choses ici position
difficile pour vladimir kramnik contre
le king
garry kasparov qui apparemment
commencerait à rentrer dans le match
oui là on dirait que kasparov a trouvé
un moyen de prendre une petite
initiative et ça c'est mieux que les
parties précédentes
lien avec les blancs cramique le tenait
à distance sans trop de difficulté
chronique doit jouer le problème c'est
qu'on voit pas beaucoup plus pour
kramnik la part d'amd 5
et oui oui chronique là il est comment
ça va être très chaud dans cette
situation il a l'air tranquille
peut-être quand même qu'il a eu un coup
au moral hier stéphane on ne peut pas le
savoir en tout cas le résultat de cette
partie nous en dira plus la qualité de
cette partie de dire à 6 g qui a été
affecté et des roues ne l'a pas été pour
l'instant
vladimir kramnik à une position resserré
difficile mais néanmoins des bons atouts
positionnelle puisqu'il a on ne le
redira jamais assez la paire de fous un
peu plus d espace donc si jamais il a
neutralisé les pièces blanches qui sont
toutes sorties pour l'instant les deux
cavaliers le foot j'ai 2 eh bien nous la
dîmière cram n'y aura non mais je crois
que comme les autres partis ce qui se
passe à ce niveau-là de la cua de la
compétition à ce niveau de jeu c'est que
l'initiative très légère ne suffit pas
mais comme on en donne et les deux
joueurs jouant à peu près des coûts qui
sont à peu près les meilleurs on arrive
tôt ou tard à une explosion sur
l'échiquier est à une phase tactique
intense effectivement
donc là je vois que il y en a un petit
rouleau qui vient d'arriver un petit
rouleau pour réparer ton micro mais tu
peux tu peux essayer de simplement de le
mettre ton micro
[Musique]
voilà vous rappelle ici on fait cette
retransmission ici à londres avec une
webcam en plastique et playskool
playskool et donc un microphone un
microphone de télé lui le bris mobile
tout à fait exactement peu de moyens
sont nécessaires aujourd'hui sur
internet vous savez pour faire une
retransmission mondiale donc le de
webcam un microphone en plastique et un
réalisateur dont je veux dire un une
personne polyvalente qui prend plusieurs
voix qui réalise qui cadre et qui fait
tout en même temps le codage et ainsi de
suite
bref il faut une personne de webcam et
un micro ça suffit pour faire le
spectacle que vous avez là c'est quand
même impressionnant c'est la nouvelle
télévision et là vous avez en face de
vous sur votre écran vladimir kramnik
qui réfléchit il est sous pression et
donc n'a cette femme je pense que comme
on ne peut pas le micro la veille au
grain voilà c'est mieux ça doit être
bien et donc la chronique au 14e coup
doit jouer à leur attention
ce crâne il utilise du temps et là ça
commence à être un petit peu marqué
puisque cramique à utiliser presque 50
minutes contre 35 à kasparov
ça veut dire qu'il a des problèmes qui
doit réfléchir aux solutions mais que
s'il continue à ce rythme il va avoir
une crise de temps normal il faut qu'ils
passent l'épreuve d'ouverture c'est pas
évident cette femme
il est sous pression
il est sous pression kasparov lui dire
tu veux changer d'âme et vas-y échanges
nous avons plein régime on joue s'était
chargé d'âmes j'ouvre la colonne de
matour et ensuite que sparrow va
sûrement amené sa tour f en c1 et
augmenté la pression des pièces blanches
alors que les pièces de chroniques sont
pas toujours sont toujours pas développé
notamment le fou ces huit étant fermés
oui je vous invite si on peut monter les
chics et de démonstrations bilan
position le problème du de crâne hic
c'est que là est bien pour nous autant
ce fou n'est pas développé alors que les
blancs vont tranquillement faire
coulisser leur tour et fin sur la case
c1 alors pourquoi cette tour évidemment
c'est pour garder la tour 1 en place en
cas d'échangé dams et tours tout de
suite à une action donc là lorsque le
toit fin elle n'en a aucune ce temps le
sert à rien vous la voler n'y a pas d'
attaque sur le roc noir donc pas besoin
de défenseurs à côté du roi
les pions devant le roi et le fou ce
sont une barrière en suffisantes donc
cette tour en f1 aurait une action
superbe sur la colonne sait où elle
pourrait aller le problème c'est que les
blancs pourront continuer à augmenter la
qualité de déplacement de leurs pièces
tranquillement alors qu'on voit mal pour
l'instant ce que cramique peut faire
malgré sa paire de fou qui
potentiellement peut être un atout en
fin de en fin de partie notamment au
final mais un kramnik que va faire
cramique que va faire comme lead c'est
la question qu'on peut se poser faut
peut-être changé d'âme envisageons donc
le coût d'emprunt b5 suivant le célèbre
principe quand on ne sait plus quoi
faire et changer les pièces
voilà d'un premier set c'est une
tentative garry kasparov là ne se
trompera pas qu'il va reprendre la dame
c'est sûr et la f5 inapte à 13 5
tentatives de déstabiliser un peu les
pièces blanches qui sont pour l'instant
trop bien placé et notamment pour ouvrir
les fous
un plan possible pour chroniquer loi
serait de jouer le e75 et e 5 e 4 donc
effectivement on peut montrer qu'après
que le cavalier joue par exemple sur la
case des deux voilà mais sinon c'est fou
ce qui arrive sur le casse des deux
revers lors des deux chroniques pour
jouer aux 7,5 avec l'idée ensuite de
jouer le cavalier noir sur la case f6
deux mètres une tour en 1 8es de jouer e
5 e 4 on prend complètement la position
pour ces fous là il ya un autre plan
aussi de défense qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on peut jouer touré recette
pour lutter pour le contrôle de la case
c7 c'est possible aussi
c'est possible aussi n'est donc là ça
ouvre un peu la position et cissé avoir
bien pour les fous de chronique en tout
cas en tout cas petit problème à
envisager pour l'instant qu'edf si c'est
impossible puisque plus de 50 minutes le
knk sport va revenir ans et 4 mois il va
être bien placé à ce qu'elle va ce câble
est d'ici il entrera tout simplement
partout sur la pièce destinée c'est
éventuellement en bicis et il attaquera
le q5
bref ça n'a pas l'air très bon pour
vladimir kramnik non s'appelle un très
bon c'est envisageable
il faut faire le monde affaiblissement
possible en tout cas c'est sûr que là
d'ici quatre ou cinq ou la position va
prendre un caractère compliqué en tout
cas complètement différent de celui
qu'ils ont actuellement pas de compromis
dans ce match en pas de parties nulles
de complaisance kramnik veut jouer
toutes les parties à fond et kasparov
aussi en tout cas quand ils allaient
blanc puisque quand il a une noire une
amende bien faire nul vide ou en restant
sous pression une autre amie kasparov
notre ami chronique plutôt oui les 2
sont sous pression
oui les 2 sont sous pression c'est un
match très chaud mais pour l'instant
c'est kasparov qui souffre le plus avec
les pièces noires et là
nick doit se décider soi apprendre la
dame b 5
c'est la position réelle que vous avez
devant vous maintenant sur la vidéo
kramnik doit soit prendre là d'un bombe
et 5 soit joué le coup à 7 à 6 moi je
voudrais plutôt beau le coût d'un enfant
dé 5,5 ou deux pions et toujours un tout
petit peu affaiblissant pas facile pour
vladimir kramnik ici on ne sait pas trop
quoi proposer il faudrait qu'ils sortent
ces pièces mais on ne voit pas comment
le talent d'un plan peut-être un plan
j'en ai trouvé une idée intéressante
mais ça ne marche pas non alors je ne la
mentionne pas mais cette position connue
autant ça devrait pas on voit quand même
proposer des plans il faut absolument
sortir sauf où sévit trailer stéphane
pour sortir le fossé mais il n'ya que
deux solutions soit on le sort par ici
comme ça
soit on le sort par là pour un enfant
donc j'envisage est en fait tout
simplement de gamme pro b 6 puis on
prend et b6 et b6 ramseyer 1
c'est très très risqué à l'autre et
risqué pendant que ça crée un trou
notamment ses six sacres 1,3 et 6 et la
casse et 7 aux sites attaqués par
exemple couteau le coutour fcn tout de
suite l'air d'être embêtant oui puisque
surtout bessette le coutour c'est cette
alerte attaqué à la fois le pion le foot
bessette lecavalier 17
et s'il vous faut bessette bouge le pion
à 7 c dans l'intérieur de santé ici tout
salaire de la sueur et des salaires très
embêtant que presse-t-il surtout
bessette quand même stéphane examens
propres par exemple peut-être tour ses
sept tours c'est cet été après fonds
points 4 et prend des soins quatre tours
prendre 17 éventuellement et tout est en
l'air tout est en l'air c'est clair ce
n'est pas bon quand c'est une ce
développement avec les 126 a l'air un
peu compromis
oui ici
non hélas il faut jouer tranquille il
faut jouer peut-être cavalli b6 revoyons
peut-être le coup est quand même
beaucoup et ça il peut être avant le
coup à fond et intéressant qu'un valet
des deux qui a aidé 2 c'est le bon coup
d'oeil g5 l'eau s'il était envisageable
il s'appelait des deux c'est mieux je
pense c'est de faire le mieux est donc
là peut-être cavalier e 5 peut-être ou
cavaliers peut-être en b6 spécialiste
notamment des six c'est plus logique
peut-être qu'à bbc attaque contrôler la
casse et 4 donc si le courrier blanc
veut y aller il y aura peut-être un
échange ça c'est important de contrôler
ça c'est clair bien et parce que là ça
peut me lasser et le plan à venir c'est
bien entendu faut aussi et que se
passe-t-il sur tours fc 1 stéphane c'est
la question qu'on peut se poser
natori siens 6 pts n est pas grave parce
que j'aurai tout 17 peut-être attaquant
le pion ah oui les 5 ha oui oui très
pertinent stéphane très très pertinent
dans la foulée 16 ou 17 contre attaque
en version v5 et surtour ses sept ont
peut-être joué tour fbi 8 tu sais pas on
commence à avoir des possibilités
effectivement l'option de 5 est une
cible mais le cube et 7 va tomber le
plus ancien to see donc
en fait tout ce qu'on vient de voir
cette assertion puisque ouais c'est pas
platini sera le même rassurant parce que
il a des possibilités
si si ici nous sommes sûrs qu'il est en
train de trouver des pistes
intéressantes qu'il en a plusieurs à son
arc il a plusieurs possibilités a dit
mercredi qu'il va choisir la bonne ça a
aucun doute là dessus et comme les
variantes convient de voir ont l'air
tendu mais possiblement tenable eh bien
ça veut dire que tu ramènes tu vas
trouver lors de coups précis pour tenir
c'est sûr en tout cas dans ce qui est
clair dans cette position stéphane c'est
que c'est les blancs et les noirs qui
ont des difficultés à trouver des coûts
pour les lancer très simple oui ils
n'ont pratiquement jamais le choix ouais
non pour les blancs aussi ils ont le
choix
non ils doivent à peu près jouer
toujours les mêmes coûts walter fcn tour
si tout restait un cavalier e 4 en d2
qui a laissé 4 apprend b5
bref que des coûts uniques mais
tranquille
intéressant à jouer tranquille mais
facile à trouver et qui ont l'air fort
donc s'avère bien pour les blancs alors
que les noirs ici anton problème que
faire pour développer les pièces si on
échange les dab on on permet aux blancs
des stores une pression telle sparrow
finalement à trouver des moyens simples
d'obtenir une petite pression dans cette
ouverture
ces moyens très simples
très moyen extrêmement simple simple
krafchick maintenant est en train de
manger le temps qui lui reste puisqu'ils
durent être 1h04 pour jouer les 26
prochain coup il passe donc en dessous
du seuil de réflexion mais c'est un
moment critique
est-ce qu'ils échangent les dames qu'est
ce qui peut faire d'autre qu'est ce qui
peut faire d'autre cramique qu'échanger
des dames on va pas trop il n'y a pas de
coups qui avait un voleur faut qu'ils
trouvent un plan des tours 8
pour préparer f5 5,4 3,8 à l'air d'être
une possibilité c'est possible on laisse
le pouce et 8 puisqu'il protège bessette
la torah 8 peut être utile à la défense
aussi
la question toro 8 peut être grave c'est
possible on peut envisager le coup tours
ouais on peut l'envisager mais enfin
c'est quand même pas un coup c'est pas
mal c'est stéphane sais pas c'est qu'un
pas un coup qu'on a envie de jouer
ouais mais touré 8 prépare quand même
poussé central qui peut très très
désagréable je sais pas c'est un coup de
d'attentes pour voir un peu ce que vont
faire les blancs et permettra au noir
éventuellement d'autres menaces et f 5 e
scène qui me l'a 104 tout tout de suite
ce qui posera ans s'était fait je n'y
crois pas en revanche je croirai plus
c'est un coup comme f5 tout de suite
suite qui a laissé cinq ça c'est
possible aussi qui paraît plus probable
enfin pas trop quand même dans cette
position-là difficile programme d'icc à
mon avis il ne faut pas bouger les pions
vous faut pas bouger les tours du tout
il faut juste se rechercher des chemins
pour la presse de ben bernanke
effectivement kramis craignent un peu
d'espacé au centre avec son petit en d4
mais sa bouche aussi le coup g7 qui
malheureusement ne table plus sur b2
d'enseignés j'ai une idée ça c'est un
petit ennui toujours pas une petite
famille difficile de trouver une idée
pour dent je pense en tout cas que cram
nique aura plutôt tendance à laisser les
blancs jouer d'un programme pour
reprendre du roi et ensuite avoir la
possibilité tour à sept qui tiendra la
baraque
je verrais bien un coup comme cavani m6
dans cette position pour vladimir
kramnik je pense que c'est le bon coup
mais qu'elle est si c'est pas mal parce
que qu alexis salaire de proposer un
échange de pièces de cavaliers nous
allons regarder qu'à la magnifique et ça
libère le pousser mythe tout de suite
probablement sa menace aussi et non ce
n'est ce pas fou 17 alors perdre une
pièce mais non mais sa menace cavani
pour cavani et stéphane t'amener à
sylvain calinon jouer dans ce cas là
cavalier f en d2 alors que nous avons un
polytechnicien qui arrive
et oui effectivement il va
pouvoir nous parler de physique
quantique mais également des chèques
puisqu'il est je crois bientôt maître
international il s'agit de jean philippe
carbon sous l'argent fini bonsoir je
vais vous laisser
et je vous conseille de regarder qu'à 26
qui a l'air d'être le coup intéressant
dans cette position peut-être même que
je vais rester un petit peu avec vous
pour commenter à trois c'est mieux donné
qu'on a beaucoup de place et que tu
marches sur mon micro
tout à fait tout à fait je marche sur
ton micro mais c'est quand même
sympathique
voilà nous sommes ici à londres et
allons donc c'est que la classe c'est
cher c'est bien connu
voilà donc alors là on sent avec jean
filles car qui est joueur d'échecs
internationale à plus de 2400 et où je
crois un peu moins un peu moins de 2000
pour rester en 2350 à pour être précis
vous perdu un peu de poids alors un
petit peu peur je suis en train de
regagner la salle avant l'infini car qui
est à l'endroit actuel ans et qui donc
nous rejoint pour commenter cette partie
alors tu as suivi j'en suis je crois la
partie d'hier en direct ici dans les
studios dans le public
oui mais j'étais dans le public je crois
que je suis arrivé pour le le jour qu'il
fallait alors qu'est ce que tu penses de
cette partie aujourd'hui de cette
position a va la chronique va jouer il a
joué à six voilà décidément la faute
donc la a6 de la part de vladimir je
vous rappelle que vous êtes en direct
sur canal web pour suivre ce match entre
gary kasparov et vladimir kramnik et
aujourd'hui nous avons des invités tout
à l'heure c'était le joueur
international jérôme sol à quillan qui
est venu nous dire un petit bonjour il à
jean philippe car joueur international
très connu sur la scène parisienne qui
fait quelques tournois intéressants il
avait notamment joué le tournoi
accession il me semble à vichy ton
accession du championnat de france qui
était relevé oui de plus en plus
des échecs français les notes
d'intention alors que penses tu de cette
partie aujourd'hui est-ce que tu as le
sentiment comme nous comme que g unique
est en train de passer un petit moment
difficile oui oui je veux étonner
d'ailleurs puisque quand j'ai lu
kasparov réfléchir dans le début je me
suis dit que j'aurais du mal à obtenir
quelque chose depuis la salle r
effectivement désagréable pour granby je
sais pas il a sûrement vu quelque chose
alors on va voir notre échiquier de
démonstration pour voir que la chronique
caffin kasparov a deux possibilités
maintenance soit échangé les dames soit
peut-être temps d'un petit piège que je
vais le voir je sais pas si ça marche
mais peut-être le ku'damm c4 ici le coût
de ces quatre ans petit piège puisque si
kramnik prend le pion b2 tout de suite
kasparov réplique par tour f en b1 et la
dame ici est prisonnière elle ne peut
aller sur aucune gazon le monde tout les
cas sont contrôlés par les blancs sauf
sauf la 15e du
un pack à 2 2 mais oui effectivement
mais tour à 2 gagne à l'examen c'est ça
donc voila apres dame prend à deux d'un
prof 2k sports peut gagner adam encore
par tour à 2 et la dame s'allier et
définitivement dans la boîte si si
oui mais ça a l'air effectivement mais
ça gagne 2 pièces pour la dame mais la
dame est dans la boîte et c'est confirmé
par la machine qui donne un peu leur
piège très sympathique malheureusement
si on revient dans la position d'homme
sekkat c'est quand même tout à fait
mauvais puisque ça permet ça permet au
noir d'égaliser très vite enjoint ne
serait-ce qu eux la voilà à 4 à 6 dames
c4 je pense qu'ici on peut peut-être
envisager le coup cavaliers en bref si
ce suivi de fous aussi ce qui chassera
la dame blanche
en tout cas c'est une possibilité car il
ya 6 il ya peut-être cavadee aux cinq
aussi qui est possible ambre enfin bref
ya beaucoup de possibilités ici pour les
noirs dame c4 s'est pas positionné lé
stéphane garry kasparov va jouer d'un
pro b si c'est l'ordinateur propre aux
cavaliers ambiguïté sur dame sait qu'un
trio dérobé vite également positionné
louer tout à fait qu'elles évitent pour
aller en c6 c'est bien joué un air rue
de la marne ordinateur kit avantage
blanc toujours donc c'est pas clair non
qu'est ce que va jouer il peut jouer
aussi donc d'anne frank b 6 tout est
possible en fait et en comptant deux v6
d'un proxy sudam ces cas de possibilité
pour les blancs
en fait en train de réfléchir la
position les choix sont encore nombreux
on n'est pas dans une variante de force
et ça me ferait que kasparov et réussi à
trouver une ouverture qui met une petite
pression soccram knicks à en prendre de
gros risques
oui oui mais là on a l'impression qu'ils
veulent échanger les dames et peut-être
joué à cinq le pion à saintes ce qui
permet de fixer complètement et les deux
pions noirs de l'élevage effectivement
baissé était hâtif voilà donc comme plan
donné par jean philippe c'est que les
blindes pourrait faire dans ces drames
d'un pro b 6 et après
kamal et prendre les six proposés le
coup à cinq qui attaque tout de suite
évidemment le cavalier et qui fixe les
pions blancs sur les cases à 7 et b6
ensuite une cible immobile pour le foot
blanc au g2 voilà le fond blanc qui va
pouvoir taper sur le clou de cette et
ensuite on va pouvoir ramener la tour
eiffel probablement sur la case c1 pour
l'amener ensuite sur la casse c'est 7 et
augmenté la pression sur le point b 7
voilà une plante pour kasparov voilà une
possibilité d'augmenter sa pression
tranquillement sans prendre aucun risque
et
de pousser chronique sur la défensive
la kasparov en train de réfléchir
toujours y'a pas le feu sur l'échiquier
encore vraiment il ya une pression d'un
kasparov alors on peut peut-être mon
agent philips qui pense quand même des
pauses exceptionnelle de garry kasparov
puisque depuis le début de ce tournoi il
nous fait quand même une série de
situations très intéressantes dont
jean-philippe que penses tu du jeu de
scène du jeu de jambes de garry kasparov
la zone euro il aurait vu quelqu'un
voilà une fois de plus donc là tu as un
très bel essai sur un téléphone portable
et encore et bien je le trouve
exceptionnel je pense pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'autres joueurs bref autant de
dison de simagrées sur l'échiquier
mais ce qui m'étonne un peu c'est que
quand même globalement une rame en l'air
satisfait de lui
et il allait un peu ces escroqueries et
non sous pression ça c'est ce qui nous
étonne tous c'est que cramique qui
arrive à poser autant de problèmes à
kasparov
donc là on a encore le droit à une
petite grimace de kasparov qu'est ce qui
se passe est probablement encore un
téléphone portable
oui c'est possible ou alors notre
réalisateur qui nous fait peu se refait
trop bruyante ou calgary kasparov et
très très gêné par les petits bruits
effectivement il faut bien le dire il la
tendance d'ailleurs à le montrer puisque
il a l'air mais cherche donc à quand il
regarde le public avait l'air très
méchant très surpris et méchant à la
fois c'est à dire qu'on n'aimerait pas
être à la place de la personne qui a un
téléphone qui sonne mêmes parce qu'un
méchant qui niveau tu veux un coup de
tête ou quoi
et oui sachant que ses deux acolytes
sont placés dans la salle postés dans la
salle la personne qui elle téléphone qui
sonne va passer un sale quart d'heure à
la sortie c'est très probable oui ils
seront ainsi à lettres à plusieurs et ça
ne se reproduira plus je pense
effectivement kasparov qui a les moyens
de l'intimider le public grâce à sa
délégation très fourni oh oh la la la
tête dans les mains
kasparov à ce moment là
ce qui laissait deux encore une fois
obligé d'échanger les dames
oui peut-être non mesdames c4 est
possible aussi obligé de changer les
dames c'est compliqué même si quatre dom
c4 on va rentrer dans des complications
la kasparov
se prend la tête dans les mains
pour calculer
beaucoup qui va jouer maintenant autant
chronique à utiliser une heure et
kasparov 45 minutes
petit avantage à kasparov autant très
léger il reste aux deux joueurs a joué
26 coups pour atteindre le contrôle de
temps rien n'a pas l'air satisfait et
kasparov après le coup de crâne nicklas
il salue satisfait pas oui c'est quand
même bizarre en gary kasparov
alors qu'on a l'impression qu'il a à
faire à comprendre parce que il al'air
beaucoup mieux il a l'air mieux tout le
monde sait qu'il est mieux
lui aussi doit le mener doit sans doute
et doit le savoir mieux mieux peut-être
pas si mieux que ça disons que non mais
qu'est ce que tu as 20 de large et garry
kasparov dans cette position le coup de
crâne a7 a6 a quand même pas l'air
percutant ça ressemble à un coup pas
très bon à excellent en tout cas pas
surprenant ça c'est sûr ouais ça force
la charge des dames
et pourtant garry kasparov fait la moue
mais de toute façon maintenant ça y est
je n'y crois plus plus personne n'y
croit
quand gary kasparov fait sa tête de
chien battu
et bien en fait il a tout vu il a tout
vu il a tout calculé en bref il bluffe
on y bluff en permanence c'est un
véritable joueur de poker malgré les
dires comme que deux jours à la belote
en fait pas du tout
kasparov la nuit joue aux échecs et au
poker mais certainement pas à la belote
c'est clair que
il a l'air quand même un peu embêté
ils en demandent pourquoi puisque
s'avérait qu'il est toujours un petit
avantage
est-ce qu'on peut montrer la position
ici de la partie voilà que cet avantage
il est quasiment obligé d'échanger les
dames ou de tenter un coup qui va
compliquer la partie le coût dame c4
possible aussi changé d'âme à l'air le
plus probable pour revenir en c4 ou
prendre la dame b6 il faut qu'il fasse
quelque chose évidemment parce que sinon
il va perdre la dame le pion à six
attaquants celle ci avec véhémence la
casse pendant cette pause de favorite
alors que que se passe-t-il après par
exemple d'un plan b 6
dans ce cas-là kramnik répondrai
immédiatement cavale et prendre le 6 et
probablement viendrait le coup à 4 à 5
hélas le ska kramnik postaux ressources
en devises sur la case des 5 et l'a
peut-être que
c'est pas évident pour les blancs
d'augmenter la pression on a
l'impression qu'à sport peut encore
mettre sa tour sur le castillan
éventuellement cavaliers ont ces cinq
aussi éventuellement le cavalier ou 4
effectivement sur la case c5 qui nous
est dit que jean philippe lecat requête
avec nous à landrin direct ici rien ces
cinq restaurants une pression sur le
plan b 7 ou alors je pense avoir compris
quand même l'idée de crown hic c'est que
dans cette position il n'y a plus
d'entrées de tours ans et 7
ça c'est très très important maintenant
il peut jouer simplement tour des huit
pour blinder son cavalier en d5 et on
voit plus trop de plans pour garry
kasparov c'est dire que le plan
principal qui était très ennuyeux pour
les noirs c'était tour serré tour ses
sept
maintenant que le québec est un des cinq
ce plan n'existe plus et c'est quand
même un problème pour derrick aspord ces
problèmes pour ça qu'il commence son
show son cinéma
là on peut le voir parce qu'en plus il a
enlevé les deux cavaliers de la colonne
du fou la c2 cavalli qui bouchent le fou
ça va falloir mettre sa carrière dès
5h30 d2 mais si ça valait ils seront
moins actifs peut-être ces cavaliers
mais aussi guy peut avoir un plan
kasparov c'est de mettre son cavalier
leucate si on va enlever les flèches qui
contiendra beaucoup dans cette position
c'est peut-être
j'enlève les flèches
alors que stéphane laborde fait le
ménage en direct pour vous sur cet
échiquier de démonstration voilà
peut-être en plein pour kasparov
c'est peut être aussi de jouer le
cavalier sur la case des deux puits sur
ces 4 et après et peut-être pour menaces
et ensuite de la matraque b6 webcam au
tram dit que ça serait peut-être à
l'autre cavaliers de fait de tout même
des cavaliers les trois vendée 2 puis 6
4 alors là notre cavalier d'un sac à
main que le cac valeo 4 se réserve pour
la case c5
effectivement mais bien sûr il va
falloir malgré ces deux cavaliers qui
font cavalier un g2 donc à rien ces cinq
ans quand on sait que la grèce ferait
peut-être vous pression peut-être une
pression finalement qui est difficile à
wes a pas l'air ça pas très convaincant
puis c'est long c'est un plan qui est
long qui va permettre au noir de se
resituer on doit revenir à la position
actuelle
l'accord sera en pleine réflexion
alors que nous sommes en train de battre
des records puisque nous sommes trois
dans un demi mètre carré stéphane c'est
quand même exceptionnel
oui effectivement un demi mètre carré
occupé ici à l'ombre où les loyers sont
extrêmement chères on ne le rappellera
jamais assez
garry kasparov dans cette position ne
sait plus trop quoi faire
on a vu le plan de crabes licra qui
aurait joué la défense précise accès à 6
empêchant le plan de garry kasparov donc
garry kasparov et contrarié dans cette
position puisqu'il ne peut pas faire son
plan
voir une position intéressante alors que
stéphane va nous quitter quelques
instants pour aller je crois à prendre
quelques impressions dans la salle
stéphane essaie de nous ramener des
commentaires puisque tout à l'heure au
café j'ai croisé des gens en disant que
kasparov était très fort c'est vrai
peut-être qu'on peut avoir d'autres
impressions
alors il va prendre son blouson
vraisemblablement voilà pour justement
sortir dans la rue deux c'est mieux
non c'était une bonne chance nous
restons ici pour les commentaires avec
jean-philippe car donc pour commenter ce
match exceptionnel en direct de londres
garry kasparov la bête contre vladimir
kramnik l'élève jean-philippe toi tu es
donc étudier les partis de ces deux
joueurs probablement et donc au niveau
du style est ce que les parties que tu
vois ici te plaise ont eu plein sont
attendus
disons qu'elles sont bien dans le style
de famille on a en général des longues
pression propositionnelle dû verser par
les blancs chaque partie d'un programme
longpré sont amsterdam c'est ce qu'on
attendait encore une fois ramenés a
réussi à échanger les dames on va se
retrouver avec un milieu de jeu se nomme
un but de joe est tout à fait une sorte
de revenu dans la partie précédente mais
avec couleurs inversées
donc cette fois ci c'est kasparov qui
joue un peu dans le style habituel de
kram nic wise babines dans comme dans
les cinq premières parties des dames
sont échangés en moins de quinze coups
c'est quand même impressionnant de
réussir à changer d'âme si facilement
compris garry kasparov et la vasière
cramé dans sa loge pour l'instant il a
dû voir le coup joué par gary kasparov
d'un prendra une forme à blanc répond
par évier prend dame je pense qu'on peut
aller chercher sur ce coup
les bookmakers anglais refusent le pari
quelle que soit la cote
cavani programme saura jouer c'est une
certitude et gary testard of réfléchi
aïe
bon ils attendent en fait car ils sont
en attente le crâne microbienne pour
jouer qui est prenable mais probablement
déjà prévu son prochain coup ouais elle
s est passé de ma mère va hésiter à
jouer tempo n'hésitera pas à tout
vitesse et sur garry kasparov en pleine
réflexion alors que chronique n'est
toujours pas revenu ou électronique
je peux bien te que peut-il bien être
bien en train de faire à ses idées
arrivé en courant de la divine
évidemment un ajout qui avait prudemment
en quelques secondes
c'est clair c'était le coup qu'on
attendait eca sport va jouer il va le
faire
il va nous montrer ce qu'il a trouvé à
une noyade une noyade à ahola la caf par
off
il est rétrécie il est étriqué à c'est
non mais alors ils étaient surpris c'est
jean-philippe peut-être pas renier mon
ami tu peux être
n'attendez pas cavalier problème
finalement il aurait été surpris par ce
coup c'est tout simplement incroyable le
coup évident aurait surpris garica soir
et non pas trop ce qui devient assez
rapide à 5 à 5 si on parlait un peu
avant et donc ensuite il ya toutes les
manoeuvres de pièces dont on a parlé
c'est à dire amener une tour ou même les
deux sur les colonnes c'est un cavalier
en c5 un autre cavalier peut-être en d2
et c4 mais le problème c'est l'ordre des
coûts et pour trouver le bon ordre
ramener toutes les pièces il faut
calculer beaucoup de variations joué par
kasparov cas ça enchaîne vladimir
kramnik et bien entendu venu en d5
sans aucune surprise kasparov
normalement a tout vu il devrait jouer
on attend quand même que kasparov jovite
l'a peut-être cavaliers f d2 comme on
l'a dit ou alors et cavaliers ed2 ou
encore tours fc un cavalier c5 et oui
j'avais le gall et c5
à noter quand même que nous avions prévu
cette variante avec stéphane laborde
healy
même plus d'une heure de cela c'est
quand même pas mal c'est la première
année que nous avions envisagé dès le
début avant même que à 4 ne soit joué
nous étions arrivés à cette position et
nous avions conclu que les blancs
étaient un petit peu mieux
c'est vrai mais là je pense qu'il ya pas
de problème pour cramique en fait après
une deuxième lecture
ici il devrait jouer simplement tourner
vite suivre sa part tour des huit
ensuite sortir s'en fout c'est vite sur
une case du n'importe laquelle par
exemple angers 4 peut-être quand même
une petite pression pour garry kasparov
à noter qu'on peut trouver aussi un
autre plan pour vladimir kramnik ça peut
être de jouer avec eux cet os 6 il faut
ensuite possible aussi en tout cas
beaucoup de plans il peut être
éventuellement b6 un jour s'il faut est
resté ans et 8 b6 un jour c'est une
possibilité également pression sur le
cube et 2 qu'on a colonisé va s'ouvrir
avec la case ses trois tours si jamais
ce puits on venait à disparaître c'est
possible donc là il ya beaucoup de
flèche on va nettoyer un peu tout ça
faire ce qu'on appelle du nettoyage dans
le jargon informatique
voilà on a une solution plus rapide pour
le faire nous allons donc
l'employé
voilà
sayedi sept cavaliers c5 joué par gary
kasparov et la can et la menace de
kasparov dans cette position qu'at-il
bien prévu de faire mais bien pour
l'instant on se le demande
apparemment d'éric laporte aura pas de
menaces a peut-être peut-être le coup
tours 1 1 à 4 pour faire pression sur le
pion des 4 alors oui granic chanteur des
beatles il y avait peut-être une menace
qui était de prendre des cats avec
lecavalier mais le problème c'était
quelqu'un reprenne du fou attaquant le
cavalier en 6 1 oui la menace n'était
nulle pa jay haas par contre on pouvait
effectivement précédé sa part tour à 4
qui attaquent l'option des cats ce qui
forcerait la réponse aux 5 pour protéger
les pions et là le coup cavaliers prend
des cats marchait il permettait de
gagner un pion s'évader 8 permet de
parer le coup tour à 4
c'est à dire que maintenant on fait
comme on voit que kasparov ne menacent
plus d'entre eux ces sept
eh bien parlons en de si on peut montrer
c'est de la route là parce que là on
peut prédire une petite réflexion de
garry kasparov colle sur le coutour à 4
eh bien on pourrait envisager le coup
cavaliers c7 avec l'idée de venir en
aussi pour lutter contre la dette la
bête en c5 ça ça peut être un plan
intéressant puisque ensuite rappelons le
crâne nique à la paire de fou et donc ça
veut dire qu'il aura un petit avantage
dans toutes les finales où l'initiative
de kasparov son aura disparu donc tour
des huit grammes nique pour l'instant à
mon avis est en train tranquillement de
faire de réduire les initiatives de
garry kasparov à 0
tout cas à peu et ensuite il va
commencer à la joue et enfin ne vendons
pas la peau de l'ours
garry kasparov évidemment à des
ressources et il est capable dans cette
position de trouver des moyens qui nous
sont échappés pour l'instant
énorme partie
garry kasparov contre vladimir kramnik
on ne le redira jamais assez c'est un
match vraiment exceptionnel ça fait cinq
ans que kasparov n'a pas remis son titre
en jeu et donc c'est un match qui est
attendu je crois par la communauté des
joueurs d'échecs
jean-philippe dont tu es un représentant
bien sûr depuis ça fait au moins deux ou
trois ans que l'on nous promet un match
à peu près tous les trois mois alors
c'est une temps en temps shirov de temps
en temps un an d'une temps en temps on
crame lic finalement un peu par hasard
c'est tombé sur cram nique et c'est pas
plus mal d'ailleurs vu ses ouailles
brumale on peut supposer que les autres
se seraient prix des dvd des déculottées
sévère tout simplement oui puisqu'il y
avait des scores assez catastrophique
contre kasparov kadyrov par exemple
n'avait jamais battu kasparov avec
ridicule ridicule avec sigh shirov qu'il
n'a jamais battu garry kasparov
il faut dire quand même que kasparov
quand il en tient un il ne le lâche pas
ça veut dire qu'il a un assailli prend
l'ascendant psychologique et le garde
l'a en tout cas kasparov en train de
perdre un peu de sa de son image de
killer puisqu'il est dominé dans ce
match et ça va donner des idées à tous
les jeunes aux dents longues
les jeunes requins qui arrivent pour
manger du champion du monde garry
kasparov c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle ce qui lui arrive dans ce match
à moins qu'il ne se réveille et on
recommence et enchaîné des victoires
et bien tout le monde va chercher à
venir le surprendre à venir se le faire
tout le monde veut se faire le champion
alors que nous sommes à deux heures de
jeu deux heures de jeu c'est est ce que
ça veut dire quelque chose dans une
partie priori pas grand chose deux
heures de jeu non tant qu' aucun des
joueurs nés en grande crise de temps
l'essentiel devrait plutôt se presser un
peu plus tard je pense oui
le money time mais et c'est vrai que
quand les joueurs n'ont plus beaucoup de
temps les fautes fusent à l'image de
cette partie incroyable celle d'hier
ah oui oui il ya eu un bel échange de
ouvert entre le 25e et le 40e coup la
position et c'est compliqué tout d'un
coup et donc semblerait qu'il ya eu une
gaffe de chaque côté nous voyons une
designer des fautes réciproque
c'était un échange de bons procédés ce
qui nous poussera à croire que les
joueurs que les joueurs donc font des
fautes tout simplement un testeur joue
cavalier d2 après une petite réflexion
bilan pendule une 2.04 restantes pour y
as part of 56 minutes restantes pour
manière kravitz et garry kasparov joue
son coup et s'en va tout simplement
laissant cramique sol sur la scène du
riverside studio en direct de londres et
la kabylie f d2 est ce que ça aurait
créé une menace
à priori oui une menace à long terme
nous allons tout de suite vous commenter
ça sur l'échiquier magique qui a validé
deux le coup joué par gary kasparov
l'idée c'est de jouer bien entendu au
prochain coup cavaliers en c4 et là on
me laissera tout simplement fou prend
des 5 alors on va faire une simulation
par exemple trois fuites faute qui a
laissé 4 oranges et 8 fautes
voilà
c'est une simulation chronique aurait
perdu de temps il y aurait fort en
descente
et après tout reprendre des syndics le
coup cavaliers en b si ce qui fait très
mal puisque ça fait une fourchette
ça fait une fourchette
voilà attaque la tour et la tour ça
c'est un plan possible c'est un plan
possible effectivement pour l'instant
c'est la position qu'a sport vient de
caler des deux a priori il veut aller en
c4 j'en finis pour voit pas trop oui
peut-être il ya l'idée d'aller en b3
pour relayer l'autre cavaliers
éventuellement oui mais le plus naturel
c'est sûrement la caisse c4 est ce qu'on
peut envisager de jouer avec l'option b
un jour tomber jouer des 6 et jean louis
peut-être g league pourrait envisager
tour b8 maintenant tout va vite ça
ressemble ou logique pour plusieurs
raisons la première étant que ça enlève
la tour de l'action du fonds g27 une
première explication autre explication
ça des champions de cette troisième
explication ça prépare encore plus b6
puisque quand les blancs vont prendre
ils vont reprendre de la tour
la pression sur le pion b2b compenser la
pression des blancs sur le pubis
donc on peut dire que si j'allais en
échanges et en la roja voulais
mentionner les caps sion c'est à dire
les d'options blanc contre les deux
soeurs noires qui sont à gauche de
l'échiquier
comment serait la position est bien
priori je dirais complètement égal si
ces captures gauche venait très chargé
tomber 8 voilà bien joué et vladimir il
joue les bons coups il est très fort en
il est vraiment impressionnant c'est
vladimir kramnik ne se trompe jamais
très impressionnant en mots très très
fort ce vladimir kramnik alors à priori
pronostics joue au petit jeu des
pronostics est ce que caracas pas on va
réussir à transformer quoi que ce soit
ou de chroniques va simplement revenir
faire nul ou voir même gagné pronostique
jean philippe pour cette partie alors
bon je vais prendre un risque et dire
que le web a très bien comment les stars
of va pouvoir gagner cette partie mais
ça c'est pas un pronostic
donc je pronostique une dijon d'accord
alors ça c'est pas spécialement une
prise de risque puisque nul c'est comme
le résultat probable maintenant
peut-être un coup de coeur peut-être
ramener gagnants n'ont qu'à sport jobit
kasparov a l'air sûr de mijoux cas et
c'est 4
il a vu quelque chose la vie garry
kasparov n'ai vu quelque chose mais quoi
une possibilité peut-être qu'il en huit
jours alors je pense que c'est le seul
coup qui empêche l'idb 6 pour les noirs
oui puisque si maintenant les noirs
jouent b6 c'est une simulation
e
alors qu'est ce que les blancs peuvent
imaginer ici j'ai pensé d'abord que les
blancs pouvaient prendre le pion à 6 en
prenant d'abord en b 6 oui c'est ça n'a
pas l'air d'être le cas
ça a l'air compliqué non il ya autre
chose ses pions prend b6 câbles hypron
v6 est peut-être le coup cavaliers à 5
dans cette élection avec deux superbes
bestioles des cavaliers d'ailleurs qui
menacerait en tout cas pour lequel il ya
cinq devenir en c6 faire une fourchette
voire même une triche est puisque
salaires à ses dirigeants ou 7 ça c'est
désagréable mais cramique évidemment
d'un la vie et la page des six puisqu'il
a joué le coup dans cette position e7 e6
bien joué vladimir bien joué on le
suppose en tout cas six l'idée
évidemment ses deux genoux fuite se font
une fille va chasser le cavaly ces cinq
cavaliers de garry kasparov
apparemment la chronique et serein
est-ce qu'on peut mettre un gros plan
sur l'ami kasparov qui commencerait à
comprendre que sa position part en
couille tout simplement sa position part
en vrille garry kasparov a priori n'a
plus grand chose dans cette position
waouh intéressant les mimiques de gary
très intéressant
vladimir kramnik quand même c'est
incroyable la façon dont la façon facile
la facilité avec laquelle défend ses
positions
oui il a pas peur de jouer des positions
qui ont l'air désagréable à première vue
et puis ben patiemment oui vhc pièce
finit par égaliser
peut-être même prendre l'aventage c'est
le coutour b8 c'est ça ressemble pas mal
au cou tour j'ai vite qu'il avait trouvé
dans la troisième partie oui tout à fait
il avait aussi réussi à s expliquer
d'une position un peu resserré pour
finalement réussir à faire nul alors là
c'est ça a l'air pas mal ça a l'air pas
mal tout ça alors que c'est le grand
retour
le grand retour qui va remplacer jean
philippe huelin jean-philippe merci
d'être passé
eh bien peut-être à tout à l'heure
puisque je crois que tu nous quittes
pour la capitale de la france dans
quelques quelques heures mais en tout
cas probables mois plus tard alors que
stéphane laborde va reprendre les
commandes de l'ordinateur grâce à sa
plastique alors là c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe on a vraiment l'impression
que kramis est en train de revenir
stéphane il vient de jouer aux 7,6 avec
des fouets fuite et le cavalier c5
emprise
nous l'avons déjà mentionné probablement
de mettre son époux sur la case et fuite
ou peut-être est-ce que casse ne pourra
pas protéger son cavalier mais le coût
b2b 4 il peut le faire bensaber un pion
puisqu'il y acquérir henri iv stepan oui
mais peut-être on peut augmenter après
la pression sur la colombe et on peut
imaginer par exemple il y en a d'autres
de toute façon variable de sable
alentours c'est aux boulangeries ils
vont garry kasparov réfléchi la a
peut-être un gros plan sur les rails là
il ya un très beau plan il avait mon
problème je trouve ça on va proposer une
solution
imaginons que par exemple kasparov jour
le bien de se parler tout seul stéphane
bien des sports vient de se parler
nivet ne se parlait le match est donc
avoir joué le coup tours fc inquiet
paraît logique
fait logique qu'il a surtout à suite on
jouerait le coût éventuel et non ça
marche pas non ça dans mon pote mais on
peut quand même montré pourquoi ça ne
marche pas puisqu'après des quatre ans
tout comme il y as cavaliers pour
environ 2004 et le cavalier c5 du tout
de suite est attaqué et mais il n'y
avait encore des options puisque
pourrait jouer non mais c'est pas ça
peut leur terre sap a l'air d'être bon
c'est dire qu'on a perdu
on a perdu un pion et ça a l'air d'être
bon mais quand même l'impression blanche
peut récupérer le client peut être
peut-être peut-être récupérer pions en
tout cas au luthier pour bkc aussi
qu'ils essaient 3 qui était envisagé oui
en tout cas à il tourne la tête garry
kasparov solal à ce moment là de la
partie
incroyable garry kasparov iliad est en
train de se rendre compte qu'il a encore
une fois pas réussi à mettre la pression
sur kramnik et il est complètement
dépité une nouvelle fois omis les
députés ps qui serait pas moins bien est
ce que carrément sa position qu'ils
étaient supérieurs ne serait pas
transformer en poubelle
peut-être que garry kasparov a
complètement délire et il a fait des
mauvais coups et vladimir kramnik
reprendrait le dessus
google gary kasparov la tête dans le sac
olalalala le spectacle continue
maintenant à qui faut-il s'adresser
stéphane quand il fait tous ses gestes
est-ce qu'il s'adresse au public à nous
ouvrir au public je crois que kasparov
tout simplement être très émotif et que
quand il ressent que sa position est
bien ou moins bien
on peut pas s'empêcher de traduire ses
émotions par des gestes
vraiment c'est une longue période qu'est
ce qui est bien sûr en plus qu'un sport
parfois rappeler que maintenant
peut-être la fatigue va jouer par
rapport à la partie d'hier la très chaud
et là il se re motive
il s'est orienté villa que bien peu
contente du tout il n'a peur chronique
quelle facilité pour défendre quelles
facilités pour défendre il est vraiment
très fort cela dit venir car nick est
vraiment phénoménal ce chronique
il est en train peut-être de faire
l'histoire
ils étaient en train de rentrer dans
l'histoire kramnik les deux seuls magic
plus complètement inattendue ça peut
rappeler ce match et doit me rappelle le
match qui avait été organisée entre
alexander ali keane et max peuvent leur
le hollandais ça devait être un match
d'entraînement pour aller keane à
l'époque c'était pas du tout en oeuvre
et ne faisait pas du tout partie des
grands prétendants à la couronne
mondiale et à la surprise générale ali
qui n'avait perdu deux matches il avait
récupéré sa couronne deux ans plus tard
avec un match revanche
mais c'était la grande surprise de
l'époque et ub ethernet faire rester un
des champions 2
du monde les plus les plus inattendus le
monde de l'histoire du jeu des cheminots
toute façon quand on aussi tu es
champion du monde qui ne jouait pas bien
mon site systématiquement max oeuvre qui
était clairement le plus faible des 13
champions du monde de très très loin
donc vous avez surpris à lille avait
battu à liqin à la surprise générale est
bon là c'est un peu différent quand même
puisque jeudi marc ramic fait évidemment
partie des prétendants à la couronne
mondiale il est numéro deux mondial et
on peut pas faire beaucoup mieux faire
beaucoup mieux comme prétendants en tout
cas prétendants effectivement si parce
que le meilleur prétendant qui avait
égalé dans l'histoire c'est probablement
fischer qui était déjà numéro un mondial
quand il a battu spassky et oui les
références historiques de stéphane
laborde sont sans feuilles la fois on va
rappeler tiennent que le classement elo
et loire a été inventé par un professeur
de mathématiques
arpad lots donc c'est le nom de
l'inventeur et a été instaurée en 1970
le premier classement et c'était un
classement qui a été refusée par la
fédération de tennis est donc pris par
les jeux d'échecs et qui représente une
force de jeu des joueurs mais qu'un
joueur moyen classés par exemple en
france à peu près un classement 2600
points et lou que 300 points elo d'écart
c'est énorme puisque en général un
joueur classé 300 points elo de plus
doit gagner un match en 10 parties pas
loin de 10 0
c'est pas tout à fait ça mais c'est pas
loin afin d'être plus tôt 8 2002 mais
c'est déjà un gros score kasparov a joué
tours fc un bien vu stéphane pauwels
yann costa rohff qui paraît logique et
la chronique cramatte images ou et fouet
fuite il a je vois là on va voir
maintenant là je pense que travelling va
réfléchir quand même réfléchir alors
peut-être une proposition nul mais donc
comme d'habitude on finit en attendant
maintenant non mais c'est quand même
intéressant ce qui s'est passé dans ce
match c'est quoi la profession nul est
venu toujours au moment où on ne
l'attendait pas les parties sont jouées
à fond
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire je vois
font ça veut dire qu'il ya pas deux nuls
de complaisance ya pas deux nuls rapide
un joueur joue jusqu'au bout 10e que la
première partie du match com qui a été
nul le assez vite au 25 août oui mais
parce que parce qu'en fait qu'elle soit
on ne pouvait rien faire ils étaient
bloqués c'est un blocus cette position
toute tentative de prendre et si d'un
côté ou de l'autre était vouée à l'échec
c'est quand même de très beaux joueurs
dès qu'il ya un petit avantage
évidemment le joueur qui al'avantage
joue à fond la partie ça veut dire que
les joueurs ce nom
font pas défaut et non en franchise
surprenant fasciste attaque la tour le
coup de crâne complètement surprenant
fourrage 6 est-ce que ce coup nos repas
et heavy pas revu par kasparov cécile a
vu d'amis sa tour c'est en b1 tout de
suite ouais tout de suite il la joue et
elle pour guérite zaoui et voilà
maintenant eh oui alors maintenant sur
fouet suite kasparov que jouer b4 oui
mais non je change tout non non
puisqu'ils iront à calais ces trois
quand même stéphane web que ces trois sa
menace rien moi je tombais 2 et voilà
ouais mais le cavalier s'infiltre nom
joue cavalier à 4 après et après par
contre la menace des 4 b 5e va être très
forte en kasparov non non non là ça a
l'air d'être une petite emme précision
finalement une chronique à jouer en
coupe surprenant mais qui n'a pas
surpris kasparov non mais la question la
question c'est pourquoi les spurs n'a
pas mis sept tours tout 18 ans b 1 et
mes passes qu'il a tentées kramnik il a
teinté cramique à faire une fois tu veux
dire que je peux encore faire un piège
kasparov c'est un piège impulsionnelle
chat au front et il menace des quatre
baies 5 instaurant une pression terrible
sur le flanc dam des noirs peut-être là
kasparov a induit cramique en erreur
c'est très possible
benon et c'est absolument impossible
travnik a évidemment vu tomber un truc
avec eux va jouer crânement grammy qui a
tout vu
alors est ce que tu l'aurais que kramnik
soit rejeté par le gène j'aimerais bien
comprendre exactement ta variantes qui
suit après x fuite alors que reims
fabrice on propose tout simplement pour
caspar de jouer le coup b2b car b2b 4
qui protège et là il ya probablement
californie 4 comme stéphane munka blick
prendre b4 effectivement à l'air
possible mais dans ce cas là on peut
compliquer la situation en jouant
peut-être cavaliers prend 1,6 et non ça
marche pas puisque vous pouvez vous on
peut le faire mais cela a recommandé
donc en fait effectivement ça n'a pas
l'air d'être aussi bon que ça donc
cramique va jouer faux et fuite
c'est très probable voilà les deux
joueurs sont en tête à tête on le voit
bien ici et surtout à fuiter bien
kasparov a vu quelque chose mais on ne
sait pas quoi tout simplement
mais il va le jouer c'est probable à
noter que kasparov n'a pas fait la force
de jouer tour ces deux qu'ils
s'exposaient à cavalli b4 qui gagnait 1
qualité
eh oui sacré kasparov il a tout vu il a
l'air dépité quand même surprenant quand
même des états soit on fait jouer aussi
vite tomber un sursaut est fou à 6 dans
ce cas là mais c'est peut-être demander
si cramique aller voir fois justice
je ne sais pas peut-être sachant pas
grand chose parce qu'en fait après faut
ensuite c'est comme si kasparov avait
joué tombé 1 il faut et fit tout de
suite donné tout à fait c'est exact de
votre tête juste un petit un petit
changement par contre sa force peut-être
chronique à jour il faut une suite
oui puisque le foin est mieux placé
rarement les chroniques en profite c'est
peut-être une précision du fait de
catastrophes qui pensaient que c'était
pareil mais la chronique peut jouer une
petite astuce qui peut changer peut-être
joué cavalier de d4 maintenant il peut
changer un petit peu
que nous vaut cette petite voix stephen
ce que je ne comprends pas kasparov se
serait-il tournés vers nous je ne crois
pas nous pouvons donc parler avec une
voix normale
une voix normale avec un micro qui
rappelons le se décolle s'est décuplée
allag kasparov autour de la tête
regarderiez stéphane très très
intéressant je vous rappelle que nos
micros sont faits avec des restes de
boîtes de conserve et oui il reste
boîtes de conserves et des fils de
cuisine tafer et win or la rai kasparov
a joué cavalier b3 il est proprement
ridicule à il faut montrer la position
tout de suite ça a pas l'air bon pour
espérance à la kasparov sur fuite à
jouer cavalier b3 et là il a l'air de la
pièce de cassandra natation une attaque
le pian des 4000 ça va faire partie
nulle c'est possible alors il tant
d'autres est tout de suite la répétition
possible des coûts stéphane janin vite à
montrer oui parce que la cram il
pourrait jouer rouge et cède pour
l'opium des 4 et attaquer ici par le
caraïbe et 3 donc kramnik pour rejouer
fou g7 pour protéger et la kasparov
pourrait rejouer comme alice est simple
et là on aurait droit aujourd'hui un nul
le rapide puisqu'il faudrait répéter les
coups et ça c'est dommage pour le
spectacle
mes chroniques peut aussi jouer mais
c'est bien pour chronique c'est bien
pour cramique mais kramnik pourrait
jouer le coup cavalli b4 gardant le
contrôle avec la tour sur le plan des 4
et ce cavalier a l'air d'être bien placé
il semblerait que ce coût soit
intéressant mais ça permet aux blancs de
s'instaurer un cavalier sur la classe b
6 oui tout à fait c'est pas évident de
laisser dans laquelle dix sur les
caisses b6 ici cram nick va peut-être
prendre la température ont joint souche
17 et 6 kasparov répète les coûts à ce
moment là il va réfléchir mais
probablement vladimir kramnik n'ira pas
sur un chemin doute sans s'assurer
qu'ils adulent en poche je verrais bien
vous l'a dit mercredi que je le fous g7
dans cette position ce serait dommage
non non non ça serait une bonne gestion
pour vladimir ouais mais ça serait
dommage pour un spectacle qui n'est pas
plus de combats dans cette partie mais
gary kasparov n'a pas su trouver en
corse
en tout cas pour l'instant programme hic
c'est bien parce que il a sûrement la
possibilité de faire nul quand il veut
on peut dire objectivement que vladimir
kramnik a égalisé dans cette position à
moins que kasparov et vu plus loin c'est
à dire que son fou g7 n'aurait peut-être
pas les coups et joue comme tour à 4
mais je ne crois pas puisqu'il refuse 17
en fait c'est sûr que non donc ici après
fou g7 garry kasparov répétera les coûts
et vladimir kramnik aussi ce qui nous
donnera donc une partie nulle
eh oui
facile facile quand même l'a dit
mercredi qu'un facile et là on va avoir
droit à une partie tranquille pour la
première fois du début du match 6
krainik répète les coûts ça va être une
partie sans histoire qu'on oubliera très
vite que va faire cramique escompté 1
qui rappelait la répétition des coups a
priori au niveau du temps il reste
quarante sept minutes à chroniques
contre 55,1 kasparov pour jouer les dix
pros 18 prochain coup ils sont à peu
près dans les temps
il ya pas vraiment davantage autant de
la part de kasparov donc là est-ce que
cramique va jouer fou g7 proposant une
pelisse hit man une partie nulle
c'est tout à fait envisageable
ça paraît assez cependant la dîmière
krainik normalement en huit jours et
s'il à l'ombre d'un petit espoir
davantage il va la saisir
où on sait que chronique est capable de
faire souffrir de garry kasparov il est
capable de pousser à la faute
est-ce qu'il peut envisager stéphane je
nous invite à regarder une possibilité
le coût 17 b 5 voilà alors on va voir
est ce que tu proposes tu proposes le
coup et sept blessés l'un des singles à
noter que l'ordinateur qu'on pense qu'à
manille de b4 alors bessette des cinq
peut-être intéressant sa mort est que ce
soit un avantage pour les blancs mais
cette médecine s'est résulté peur
après la flambée six prises en passant
les blancs ne pourrait prendre le
passage vous rappelle que la prise en
passant c'est la possibilité pour les
blancs de prendre sur la case vide quand
le pion se déplace de deux cases et qui
permet de faire disparaître le pion tout
de suite
voilà une démonstration le pion a
disparu c'est le seul moment où on peut
prendre sur une case où il n'y a pas de
pièces et maintenant on reprendrait donc
avec le cavalier reprendre avec le
cavalier est là que se passe-t-il est là
et bien tout simplement probablement le
coup qui avait 10 et 80 cents cavaliers
en a cinq effectivement qui a l'air de
bien contrôler les cases blanches avec
l'aide du fou j'ai deux équipes pros qui
menace une invasion sur la casse ces six
ici restaurant une fourchette
oui tout est donc ça a l'air quand même
très embêtant très présent les cinq
étapes à dire tout avance dû tomber et à
bannir puisque ça permettrait
systématiquement auxquels ces quatre de
venir sur les castillans voilà la
position actuelle et l'a probablement un
petit peu de ménage cicrane ne pas faire
nul il faut jouer le coup cavaliers b4
ou le couffo jet set et peut-être joué
le 5 et m6 avant leur fuite
wii noire s'annonçaient j'ai beaucoup de
mal à y croire envisageons peut-être le
courtier bécade stéphane pour voir un
peu quels sont les tenants et les
aboutissants de cette possibilité au
lait b4 allaire envisageable
alors la cram unique est en train de
réfléchir à l'idée de parler les cats
évidemment que la tour d vite ici
contrôler le pian des 4 alors pour
l'instant vous avez krainik à l'écran et
nous avons maintenant l'échiquier
québécois la tour des huit défendre sur
des cartes c'est vrai on n'a pas créé de
menaces apparemment est-ce qu'on peut
pas envisager de remplacer ce cavalier
sur la case de ces six là on a donné la
casse b6 quand même on peut envisager
qu'ils essaient quatre investissements
stéphane on peut envisager cavalli ces
quatre ans b 6 sur quoi
sur quoi on ne voit pas est absolument
pas comment les noirs pourraient être
mieux dans cette position non c'est pas
possible
g nick ne jouera pas ça il faut bien le
dire kramnik va jouer probablement autre
chose probablement fou j'ai sept nuls
rapide
bon c'est une possibilité voilà position
avec un mal-aimé 3d kasparov kasparov
petite frappe aujourd'hui et qui ne
réussit pas encore une fois à poser des
problèmes notre année là à noter que
comique réfléchi parce que c'est le
retournement il vient de dépasser le top
il a passé l'initiative de kasparov et
maintenant c'est lui qui a l'initiative
c'est lui qui a les possibilités avec
cette paire de fou qui l'a pris depuis
le début
graves est en train de réfléchir à une
solution pour essayé d'activer sa paire
nos fous le problème c'est quand même
que ses pions à 617 sont quand même
faible
créé sous la pression du fou g2 qui de
son poste éloigné exerce une pression
latente sur ce pion ouais nan nan mais
ici cramique bon il a réussi à passer
des initiatives de cascades et les
classes noir aussi sont affaiblis et loi
puisque les cases à 7 et b6 et ses sets
sont faibles notamment la case b6 il
faut noter qu'une nul est possible d'une
seconde à l'autre
stéphane effectivement si cram dit que
je fous g7 que kasparov reviens et je
cassais 5 très vite en disant nitzschia
ou et il est probable que rami qui
acceptent assurément une chronique à ce
moment-là voit une autre possibilité en
tout cas quand il peut répéter les coups
une fois et après
et pour gagner un peu de temps ça se
fait ça puisqu'il faut répéter ce propos
la position pro qui est nul on travaille
pour répéter la position une fois et
ensuite essayer de dévier à la troisième
fois pour éviter la répétition de trois
fois et ça lui permet de gagner quelques
coups pour atteindre le 40e coup étant
donné qu'il est un tout petit peu en
retard au temps juste treize minutes de
retard c'est très très peu ou parti qui
aujourd'hui d'être kasparov vous
souffler après la partie d'hier
oui mais elles sont là fait kasparov qui
est demandeur de time out et c'est
plutôt bien pour vladimir kramnik qui
rend les blancs aura une journée entière
pour se préparer avec les blancs
effectivement et qui évidemment s'il n'a
pas souffert dans cette partie c'est une
autre fois de plus ont d'ailleurs pour
le match ça veut dire que sinon on
calcule bien kasparov frappe toujours
les moulins le dimanche après la partie
du samedi
effectivement et ça veut dire que c'est
très bien c'est à dire que cramique a
toujours du temps pour préparer ces
parties avec les blancs oui alors que
kasparov n'en a pas alors que kasparov a
toujours du temps pour préparer cette
partie avec les noirs oui mais on sait
bien que c'est non je ne sais pas c'est
quand même avec les blancs que les
joueurs foncent plus souffrir
l'adversaire oui mais enfin s'il ya un
trou dans la préparation avec les noirs
et bien c'est bien d'avoir du temps pour
pouvoir le combler alors qu'avec les
blancs on n'a jamais trouvé la preuve
kasparov ici pas de problème il fait nul
ce n'est pas grave il n'a pas réussi à
percer la berlinoise de crown vic et
bien pas de problème ils jouent ces
quatre effet nul effectivement alors que
sam est à noter quand même que c'est une
petite dissymétrie ce qu'il faut voir
dans ce match pour l'instant on va
profiter de la longue réflexion de la
lumière chronique ici en direct de nos
jours c'est que justement c'est kasparov
qui change régulièrement d'ouverture
alors que gravelines lui reste sur des
bases solides joue toujours son
répertoire et kasparov on dirait qu'il
est en train de le tester mais que ça ne
lui réussit pas trop
j'espère que je réclame ni dans cette
position est ce qui va accepter la
proposition implicite de nul de kasparov
et ce que chronique pourrait pas jouer
le cros curieux cavaliers en s'est cette
fois montré curieux stéphane carrier en
ces sept comme nous l'avons déjà dit
qu'elle épaississe c'est très ennuyeux
et des clics et des 520 et bien il ya ce
coup qu'avec ces quatre ans b si ce qui
est très très fort et bien b6 et là
l'idée évidemment c'était protéger en
bessin si l'option des 4 mai mali
signorino sauf si mr c1 avec de la
pression ouais mais n'obtiennent pas
vraiment de pression puisque maintenant
le cas à libé 5 contrôle à la fois le
pion des 4 et la casse ces sept
oui mais quand je dis qu'il ya de la
pression c'est que les noirs n'ont pas
vraiment de coup torcéen avec line et
peut-être qu'elle est noire peuvent
jouer peut-être après le coût 5 pour
libérer leur fou et là ça obligera les
bleus en ont annoncé lundi leur
intention c'était fun tour c'est un crée
une menace on menace de tout prendre et
de finir par prendre l'option b 7 à
l'arrivée
oui avec le pion à 6 qui sera aussi
emprise et ça ferait une horreur donc là
c'est pas vraiment bizarre dont la
position est la suivante est
vraisemblablement vladimir kramnik va
replacer son faux soutient catherine
avec peut-être des idées
en tout cas apparemment kasparov
n'aurait plus trop de possibilités dans
cette position donc pas de problème pour
v cas où l'avenir krainik qui s'en sort
plutôt facilement pour l'instant
donc une partie qui aujourd'hui est une
partie tranquille semble-t-il kramnik
essaie de trouver des contres chance il
sait qu'il a réussi à égaliser la
position kasparov propose implicitement
caspar propose implicitement la nulle
dans cette partie et ça va permettre aux
deux joueurs de souffler après la partie
d'hier qui était la plus longue du match
qui a duré l'on vous le rappelle à peu
près 6 heures 30
donc qui est arrivé quasiment au bout
des possibilités de temps qui sont loués
aux joueurs et aujourd'hui
il semblerait que kasparov n'est
toujours pas réussi à trouver les coûts
nécessaires pour créer des problèmes là
dîmière kramnik